Oh Shit.
Tommy pumps with live yo dog.
What's up brother?
What's up man?
We already did a podcast.
We totally did.
Yeah,
we just,
we just went off.
We started going off about everything.
That was really lost in it to me too.
Well,
excuse me folks.
We're slightly intoxicated.
Yeah,
that's what happens.
Dj Dad mouth,
you know what I'm saying?
Have you done any variations to Dj dad
mouth now?
Have you got bored with it or you.
I'm totally bored with it.
I just stopped doing well.
I just haven't actually done that much a
morning tv shows lately.
So there was a bunch of those in a row
that cut down with folks.
I'm sorry,
I didn't even drink the butter coffee.
Um,
what did you decide to just stop doing
those things?
They stopped it.
I,
you know,
if I was doing morning press tomorrow
and I just wanted to do something to
entertain myself,
I would just do it again.
I met a lot of really nice people on
Morning TV.
Yeah.
But it's the most restrictive venue.
It's really,
it's a bad idea from the,
from the thing is here,
like comedy clubs or just thinking we
got to let as many people know about you
to sell tickets.
There's a certain point when you're a
certain type of comic basically,
where you're like,
that's not my,
my audience is not gonna find me there.
People aren't going to come because of.
I just feel like it's a waste of time
with certain comics to do.
Good Morning Toledo,
you know?
Yeah.
Like what percentage of the people that
are watching.
Good Morning Toledo would like your app.
Yeah,
it's real low.
It's,
it's not,
it's not high.
You know what I mean?
So you go sure though.
Like who watches those?
Who Watches those morning shows?
If you had a guest?
I guess mostly yeah,
I would say mostly.
Mostly housewives.
Yeah,
with their children.
Young children.
And then they get,
you know,
the guy's like,
I'm gonna show you how to make a chicken
that really isn't here when we come
back.
You know?
What about retired people?
Would that be on the demo?
And then you don't know what you don't
see.
A lot of at my shows,
but like moms stay at home mom or
whatever and retired people so they're
not asking.
Yeah.
It's a totally different art form folks.
They don't really.
They do the blast.
Some people are good at though.
Yeah.
Like,
oh,
there's some are good.
Did you ever see Tracy Morgan when,
when he was pulled his shirt up but
still started hitting his stomach and he
was saying that someone was getting
pregnant.
That's probably the best.
Good morning.
Anything of all time.
And he was in Chicago and I think he
ended up.
He goes,
Horace Grant,
which is,
you know,
the old power forward for the Chicago
Bulls.
That was such a great fucking Improv
line right then.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That was like the,
the button on the whole thing where
you're like,
Jesus,
he just shout it out.
He told him that.
It's so funny.
It's the best one.
Tracy Morgan's fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
He was slapping his belly and he's
saying someone was getting pregnant.
It's absurd.
So people get to pay to see your show.
They'll just see you smack it on your.
Take all the power back.
Wait a minute,
I've got to take the power back.
Where the back.
Oh,
we just lost your microphone on your
phone.
You might want to put taxes.
Come on.
Don't go to this texts.
Just the sample of what people can
expect more shirtless.
Actually love James t dot kirk.
I went to Vietnam.
Tracy,
one of your favorite characters.
Characters.
He knew one of my wheelchair globe with.
Fingers cut off.
I'm going to step back a little bit.
Spoonie.
Look,
can you do that for me?
This is the character.
You don't.
One of my terrible,
I guess.
Let me see.
Spoonie love was,
um,
shame.
More graphic.
Yeah,
you're right.
You can't get this children watching.
But I did get this leg blown off.
So that's.
I love.
That's nice.
Me.
Come see me.
I'm at the comic strip,
the comic script.
Tracy Morgan will perform this week.
Still available.
Who knows what's going to happen?
I was just can keep up on that.
The,
uh,
the um,
the horace grant reference in that
Chicago one is.
So it's such the funniest choice.
It's such a little detail.
Like that was so funny that he went
like,
I need fingerless wheelchair because he
said he's already thinking this is what
it's like to sit in a wheelchair.
But I love when the shout out like it
was in Chicago.
So you're thinking bulls.
Anybody could have said shout out to
Michael Jordan.
Right.
Or second most famous Scottie pippin and
it's still funny.
But like the reference to almost like it
was like an inside bulls reference,
you know,
it's like so specific to you.
It's like the perfect third on the list
name to shout out and plus the name
sounds better.
Horace grant is just a better name to
yell,
you know the name?
Horace Horace Grant.
And then the newscasters are like,
alright,
see you later.
Like they don't know what do.
It's so funny though.
Yeah.
That guy was trying to get them to do
impressions while he's in the middle of
that.
That was in Chicago by the way.
Where was that?
That was Texas.
Why was that guy trying to get them to
do impressions while he's in the middle
of that amazing rant?
He didn't know what to do.
Do you think that people were in his
ear?
Were they telling them,
uh,
they're like,
just watch him time to change it.
Get them to change it,
change the subject.
Did they put something in his ear,
do you think?
Did they,
those guys have earpieces?
Yes.
Usually most of the time,
yes.
Earpieces is weird,
man.
When someone's talking in your ear and
you're talking is one of the most
distracting things,
it's very difficult to hear someone talk
and then still maintain.
You guys do that in the fights.
Very rarely.
There are so good at,
but when you pop it in,
they never talked.
They never talk over me like there's
never,
I mean,
they're so good.
Is that earpiece feeding you anything
though or just.
Yeah.
Your voice is that producers can.
I can,
we can talk.
We're going to ask them about a specific
replay,
like,
show me that again.
Can you show me that for an overhead?
I want to see where that landed or
things along those lines.
But um,
and uh,
sometimes I mark della Grotta and I will
have conversations like I'll ask him
like,
is this a good thing?
I'm a good piece of advice that
someone's given.
Do you agree?
Do you agree with that?
And he and I will have discussions about
whether we agree with certain tactics.
Sure.
Which is an interesting discussion
because mark is like a real world class
trainer knows a lot about Moitai
specifically and a lot about mma.
Did they ever feed you something where
you like,
it totally blows your mind like,
Oh shit,
I didn't realize that's what happened.
And sometimes God damn it,
we have sometimes you'll see something
like they'll see something on a replay.
Maybe someone catches it like a,
a break,
an ankle or a weird role of an,
of a knee or something like that.
Yes,
I do watch this,
look at it.
We'll get to that.
And then you go,
oh,
she'll show it to me.
Yeah.
And I go,
Oh yeah.
So we'll have like conversation,
like,
Oh yeah,
we need to show that.
And then we'll replace something.
Wow.
I was thinking until I was watching it,
I was just looking on instagram that you
were in Toronto and you did a show and
then you did the fights the next day.
And I was thinking as like watching you
do the call,
the fights.
I was like,
man,
there's no other broadcaster in the
major sports were like the night before
he had as good a time as you did.
Like there's no way Al Michaels and
Chris Collingsworth or like tonight
we're going to fucking party with like
fans and then tomorrow we'll call the
cowboys and the giants like that never
happens for sure.
Yeah.
You get to like really have the best
trips that are work trips.
When you think about it,
you know.
Oh yeah,
they're so fun.
It's fucking nuts.
But even when I don't do a show,
you still love the fight.
UFC is awesome.
Of course.
Live watching live fights man.
Especially now that I'm loosened up my
schedule so I to go,
um,
I go like half as much.
And it's only North America.
Yeah.
No,
none of those big crazy trips.
It just take too long.
They break you down,
it takes too many days to recover from
them.
It's killer,
it kills you.
Um,
but on top of that it's a,
it's like that's the right amount for me
to just still be super enthusiastic
about it and there's nothing like it.
I mean,
I'll tell you,
I didn't become a hardcore mma guy,
but now I watch it casually and enjoy
it,
but the whole reason is that I went to
it live.
Going to alive changes your perspective
completely.
There's nothing like it.
Yeah.
I've only been to a few other sports
live.
We've been to baseball games,
basketball games.
Been to a hockey game.
Basketball lives will change your
perspective.
Yeah.
Just how enormous they are,
how athletic and how fast and the shit
is.
Yeah.
It's incredible when you see the
footwork and the movement when they like
doing some sort of a crazy layup.
Yeah.
It's like God damn,
it's super athleticism while people are
trying to stop you from doing it.
People in not that much space.
When you're at basketball live,
you're like,
that's not that much room on.
Especially on on a half court,
you know,
it takes this laser beam focused to be
able to stop and put that ball exactly
what you want,
skill to the way that they pass.
Actually,
you know,
Lebron's like on top of being this super
athlete and everything,
his passing skills are absurd.
You could look at a passing real time
and you're like,
how did he even.
I think even people that play
basketball,
how did you even do that?
Because he'll go in a direction and
anticipate that someone's going to be
somewhere else within seconds and then
we'll behind like behind his head pass
it and it's you,
you just can't put it together.
You're like,
do you think these are the things they
work on?
They must,
it must work.
I think so.
I think they work on it,
but I think at,
at their level and players like at his
level,
it's just second nature.
It's not so much improvisation.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's kind of a creative game and a lot
of ways.
Dude,
it's.
Yeah,
it's really,
it's really fucking amazing to watch
high level,
high level anything.
I mean,
I don't like soccer that much,
but I will watch like I don't watch it
regularly,
but when World Cup comes on I'll,
I'll turn into like a,
a mini fanatic.
You got to watch it with Ian Edwards.
Oh,
he's a fucking really hardcore.
He's hardcore.
He has his own podcast about just about
it.
Yeah.
Him and some other dude.
Who's the other dude that he does it
with?
You know,
Jason Glaring,
right?
Is it gluten?
Oh,
gluten and him did it.
Did it at one point.
I know for sure.
That's funny.
Funny Guy.
He's a fucking hilarious comedian.
Really Funny Guy.
Yeah.
We're talking about um,
um,
I was kind of,
I was going to bring something out so I
probably can't talk about this yet.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We're just gonna Bring,
so say something nice,
but I don't think we can talk about it
yet.
But I'm Martin Harris.
That's what he does it with.
So maybe does somewhat glaring.
It's glaring.
Glaring is a big soccer player.
Take big soccer guy.
Yeah.
High level ever watched like that.
What's that little dudes name?
Messy.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
there is.
You got a cutup Jamie's wizard.
We get to,
he,
he might.
Me and this dude,
this dude's like 24 or 26,
you know?
Yeah.
And he's um,
this just technical wizard wizard now.
He's amazing.
I've watched these highlights,
man.
I've,
I've watched a bunch of his because it's
fascinating just to watch somebody that
good at anything,
you know,
if you told me like I just tweeted out
this thing today about it dark player
and they're like,
this is one of the baddest motherfuckers
in darts.
I'll watch that.
Do throw darts for hours.
Look at this,
look at this dude,
this guy's a wizard.
Look at this.
Just embarrassing.
Just wizardry.
Yeah,
that guy,
he moves like a wizard.
It's like what he's able to do with that
ball,
it's just fucking astounding.
Yeah.
And that would be so much better than
people to do something like that.
And then the thing I always think about
remind myself as of is that he's so much
better than people who are really great
at it.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
He's not playing me out there,
you know,
like those are other professional.
Yeah.
And he's just like,
I'm gonna eat man.
You're not going to want to talk to your
wife or your mother after this game.
Well,
occasionally there's fights like that to
get the shit.
At least these guys,
they're getting humiliated,
but nobody's getting hurt.
Oh,
okay.
Wizardry.
That is just fucking straight up
wizardry.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Like his footwork.
It's just,
it's like he's doing a different thing
than them.
If a did he get tripped over the
referee?
So what happened there?
It looked like it directly.
So what happened to the referee?
Get in the way.
The referees get in the way.
That's annoying.
Dude.
In football in our football team was
wearing stripes.
You,
there's some big time for collisions.
Uh Oh yeah.
My Gosh.
These nash over the Middle Shit where
the guy's like and he's like 64.
My God turns and just.
Yeah.
You see the dies.
No,
no,
but there's the same again,
be on some of them.
Some of them are horrific men and a
regular person.
He didn't get hit by a football player.
Yeah,
there's,
there's only a couple rafts that stand
out as really in shape in football.
A couple of that.
Most of them just look like a healthier
and more fit,
but normal bodied guy.
Then there's ad hoc gillies and there's
another guy who are a little more
jacked.
Little bit.
Yeah,
a little bit.
There's this dude who invented this
thing called the iron neck.
His name's Mike Jolly.
Oh yeah.
I'm going to get this out of my throat.
Folks know this.
I know it is,
isn't as annoying to me that is to you.
But uh,
he came by to um,
it was hockey least.
C'Mon man.
He's 60 something.
Sorry.
Oh my God,
that guy's going to get killed.
He's going to get hit by something.
No,
but look,
he's in shape saying he's,
he's one of the lookout.
Like he's an older guy and he's
definitely shaped.
Yeah.
But even though if you're an older guy
and in shape,
you're getting hit by an NFL player.
Point is this guy came over here to
demonstrate Jesus Christ.
He came over to demonstrate this thing.
He's a fucking giant.
Huge.
He just thinking like if this guy,
this guy played football,
I played football and he played football
and we ran into each other.
Yeah,
that would be terrible for me.
Yeah.
Like there's a different kind of person
out there,
these,
these like,
unless you've been around like a pro nfl
player,
you see them walk through a crowd of
people and you go,
Oh man,
I just met Jj Watt.
I just met him like a month ago and I
was like,
like,
people call me like big fella that I
meet,
you know,
guy big fella.
Amen.
I know you're a big guy,
you know the,
all that stuff in your head.
You're like,
I guess I am a big guy.
And then you meet that dude and like I
was,
I looked like a child next to them.
You know,
like I looked like a,
an actual,
like a little boy meeting a superman or
something.
There's a giant human being.
He's a giant,
giant,
enormous man.
They make people.
We watched a,
or we looked at this website that held
up all the various heights and weights
of like nfl players from 20,
30 years ago in Paris.
In today.
It's like night and day.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
When I was a kid I remember lineman
like,
which is the biggest players in
football.
We're like two 75 was the standard way
and when people would say that you go,
that's a fucking humongous got.
I mean I'm like eight,
nine years old,
you go to 75 and that was the thing and
it was a big deal.
If a guy weighed 300 pounds and if
you're over 300,
you were an anomaly like human
refrigerator.
The fridge.
Right?
So that was the thing.
It was like,
he was like the biggest human in the
NFL.
They call them the fridge and he was
like fatter and everything,
but they couldn't believe,
you know,
it was a thing to be like,
this guy is over 300 pounds.
Now if you weighed 300 and you were
playing on the line,
you'd be underweight.
You'd be one of the light guys because
there's guys that are 3:30,
3:40
playing that position and athletic guys
too,
while to really huge man.
Really,
really?
How much bigger can they get?
Like what's maximum size?
I thought about there was this guy who
played,
but he wasn't really great,
but he was six,
eight,
406.
Eight,
400 pounds.
Yeah.
That's a human being.
Exactly like imagine if like everybody
was six,
eight,
400 pounds.
The world would be a different place.
It's a different thing.
That's a different kind of human being.
Six,
five to 89,
but this guy's really fast.
Really athletic box jump.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Click.
It would just look what that just says.
It says he made a
61 inch box jump.
That is insane for the average person to
understand how insane that is.
Like how do.
How do you describe how insane it is to
watch a almost 300 pound man?
Yeah.
Launched himself literally five feet
into the air.
Here we go.
Look at this.
That is fucking insane.
That is insane.
Like the size of this perk I stood in
the middle of his wife says,
oh my God.
It's insane.
Wow.
I mean,
he,
he's,
he fucking launched himself in the air.
Big Fuck Man.
That's so hard to do.
Yeah.
Like what?
He just did like one stand of like super
athletes could probably do it.
Right.
How many people could do that?
Jamie?
You're a big.
I'm one of very few in.
There's a couple of guys that,
I don't know.
It's not five feet,
but like easily three to three and a
half feet to jump out of the pool.
Oh,
I've seen that with weights in their
hands to Bj Penn can do that.
So it can.
Chad Mendez really crazy.
Yeah.
This is a.
But those guys or smaller guys is
humongous guy.
Dude.
Bj,
uh,
he's fought his heavy as heavyweight.
Really?
Yeah.
Bj fogg.
He fought heavyweights.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
He was say like five nine.
What's that?
Five.
Nine.
Is that right?
Yeah,
somewhere around there.
Yeah.
He fought Leo Machida.
He felt the a Cheeto and look,
Leo Machida was a,
you know,
clearly 200 plus pounds in the Machida
had knocked out rich Franklin to what's,
what's Bj's like walk around weight now.
He's pretty light because he's fighting
at 1:45.
But if he was five and will he be like a
one 61 70 guy?
Yeah.
If you got up.
If he got.
If he wasn't doing a lot of cardio,
I bet he probably walks around like one
60 or something like that.
But he won the 1:55
and he won the won 70.
What happened in that heavyweight fight?
He Won.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
I think he wanted to.
Leo Machida.
I think he.
No,
no,
he lost Leo.
Machida he lost a decision.
See if that's true.
I believe that's true.
I think he lost a decision.
Does it say that anywhere?
I know he fought.
He left the UFC,
fought a couple fights at other
organizations.
He fought Bang Ludwick in Japan.
And uh,
and he had a fight with Leo.
Machida.
You got it.
Your own cheer.
Me.
Yeah.
That's it.
Look,
the mosquitoes,
he was big back then.
Liotta wanted a decision.
Yeah,
crazy.
The Oda goes on to be the UFC light
heavyweight champion and Bj's now
fighting as a featherweight was
incredible.
I mean,
that's a really nutty thing that
fighters do when you try to win and
compete at different weight classes.
Pj just didn't give a fuck.
He was so confident.
Particularly early in his career.
Yeah.
I was.
One of the things about him when he
would fight,
he just had this intense belief in
himself and he would be super,
super aggressive too,
like you knocked out this dude count,
you know,
and like six seconds and count.
Who knows?
A really good fighter.
You.
Uno is very experienced.
He's fun.
A lot of like real world class guys in
Japan and he was a real respected
grappler and it was interesting matchup
because of Bj scrapping pedigree like Bj
was on the Monday aisles and count Luna
was thought to be like a really good
grappler,
real,
real solid wrestler and submission guy
and.
But pj just storm data just stormed out.
Um,
and just starched them.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
Believes that he's gonna knock you out.
He was just so good.
People who didn't get to see him live
and he was in his prime.
Bj was so good.
He was so good.
Like when he beat Diego Sanchez,
I remember thinking damn like that was
what I think what you call it peak Bj.
Bj was like,
he beat Sean Sherk who destroyed Sean
Sherk who was a really tough fighter.
Like people forget how good Sean Sean
Sherk was up like a human pit bull.
This dude was just jacked,
super strong wrestler.
Just super,
super good.
So Vj,
go into it with a,
like a trained background or just like a
scrappy fighter,
you know,
he was very trained,
he's very technical,
especially on the ground.
He's,
he's really high level and it's
Brazilian Jujitsu.
Super Technical.
And he stopped because he was like that
when he came in to fight it.
Yeah.
I don't know like where,
when is,
when he started his striking out,
but I know he got his black belt in
Jujitsu in three years,
which is just bananas fast.
Like one 10th of one percent fast.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
I mean for most people,
like you getting a black belt in Jujitsu
is like,
like if you're a real [inaudible] you
can get it into like seven years as a
phenom.
Yeah.
There's a few guys that'll get it
earlier.
You know,
like if you have some particular talent
physically,
which seems like a lot of people equate
martial arts,
rightly so with technique is the most
important thing.
It absolutely.
Yes.
But another thing that is almost as
important as technique is physical
dexterity of your body.
Yeah.
What you can do and what you can't do
with your body.
Some people are super flexible,
like pj PJ's ridiculously flexible and
Bj would rap guys up with his legs.
His legs are like weapons.
They're like arms really.
He chokes you with his arms and he's
choking you with his legs?
Yeah.
Wow.
He's,
he has incredible dexterity and
flexibility with his legs and that's
always made bj particularly dangerous on
the ground and it's just smart about
fighting.
It just is very good at understanding
when to push things,
when not to where,
where he's,
you know,
he just,
just like with everybody,
you only fight a lot of tough fighters.
You're going to have some losses,
you know?
That's,
that's essentially what happened to Bj.
That's fucking rough businessman.
It is a rough business.
God,
Vj still fighting.
Now he's going to fight this kid named
[inaudible] Rodriguez,
who is.
Hey,
have you ever seen that guy?
How long has bj been fighting for?
I gotta say Shit.
He must've started his career in the
early two thousands.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's a long time.
Yeah,
a long time to fight.
Well,
he was,
you know.
Yeah.
I would like to.
I would like to guess he probably
started fighting somewhere around,
well,
let's find out more.
Go 15 years of scrapping.
Wow.
That's a lot.
So that.
Yeah,
it's just when you,
when you see it live,
you understand like really firsthand
what the actual real consequences of
these exchanges are.
Live for me was just also the,
the excitement around it.
There's,
I mean,
it's an arena with people so jacked up
for a fight and you know,
like I think you've said like nothing in
and of itself is as exciting as a fight,
you know,
like a fight,
a fight in any moment is exciting,
but when you have a,
uh,
an arena full cheering with excitement
to add to that,
there's something that you can't
duplicate.
You know,
on an energy level it breaks.
The consequences are so high.
The consequences are high,
but there's like,
there's an energy in the room,
have somebody walking up and you hearing
that,
like,
that raises the hair on your neck and
you're like,
oh God.
And then with everything that lands that
cheering,
whoa man,
it's just,
it's,
you can't,
you can't mimic that,
you know,
neon.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
I hate the phrase because we set it for
so long and it's as real as it gets.
Yeah.
But it is just.
So you know what,
what is it about a phrase when you say a
phrase too long,
they just stop.
Meaning anything.
People start to miss phrases,
work beats talent.
When talent refused to work,
hard to write,
but I know that's true,
but I fucking hate it when people say
it.
Yeah.
Don't say it.
Say it too much anymore.
They hate it.
I start.
One's done.
Right?
It's a fucking terrible.
Yeah,
but there's certain ones like as real as
it gets done.
Yeah.
I mean,
this guy,
he used to say it anymore.
Say you gotta you gotta stop and smell
the roses sometimes to talk about life.
Then I really,
he just started antidepressants,
so I was like,
Ugh,
this is just like the medicine talking
because he was just always like,
you know,
and then you stop and smell the roses.
I'm going again.
I know you said it three times already.
Hey,
let me ask you this,
do it because you're in the middle of
this wild.
It looks at my horses back.
You're in the middle of this wild,
crazy bet with Bert Kreischer to see who
can lose the most weight by January,
first,
second and third.
Right.
You're going to weigh in three days in a
row.
I'm going to emcee it.
Fuck yeah.
We're doing at the forum.
You know that right?
Fuck.
What are you going to do it?
What's the forum?
The forum is a,
is uh,
the Great Western Forum.
Yeah.
That's where the wind is going to be.
And that's what I was told.
I don't know.
Really.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Actually,
I think we'll do it.
Can we do it here so we can weigh in
here,
live on the air.
We could do that.
But if you want to do it live in front
of a crowd,
we can do it anywhere.
I don't.
Did you want it?
You really guys really want to do it
live.
And that's a joke.
I was like,
man,
you probably could do it.
Yeah.
Um,
we,
uh,
we get a couple thousand people in the
forum.
So you guys,
and you're unaware of if I'll do it.
If we can get a couple of those ring
girls,
but that look way different than those
really big ones.
Real heavy,
real heavy ring girls,
then I'll do it.
That's what it's fat shaming though.
You can't.
If you start using heavy risk thing is
fat.
It doesn't matter.
You're a guy.
That's true.
You can take it.
Yeah,
you can take you guys.
You'd never accused of fat shaming.
This is so crazy.
That term is.
I'm Ronda Rousey who's of course,
you know,
former UFC bantamweight champion.
Yes.
All time.
Great mixed martial artists.
She has this girl,
Julianna Pena that is in her weight
division and they.
They talk shit to each other or at least
Juliana has been talking shit about
Ronda Rousey and Ronda Rousey,
which you was saying was that Ronda
Rousey has large arms.
She said she was fat arms.
Really.
It was one of the things you're saying,
but just so innocuous.
Then people were saying that she was fat
shaming or you are you really?
Seriously.
First of all,
protecting Ronda fucking Rousey.
I think it's really more about that.
The lady that said it,
that's to her such a horrible thing to
say,
you know they're going to fight is my
point here,
but she eventually made.
He's like,
I might lose that fight.
I don't have fat ass arms like you do
and that to her,
she always had these awesome arms.
I think.
Yeah,
because I mean somebody to go after
that,
like that's for her a big deal,
you know those,
but yeah.
Rhonda doesn't need any,
any defense.
Rhonda is really thin,
like she's really thin now she's chance.
Amazing.
Of course,
but I mean she's got muscles,
man.
You know what I mean?
She's got some big ass shoulder muscles
and big arm muscles.
This is a reason that not all fat things
are launching chicks through the air.
Yeah.
She's,
she's,
she's got plenty of.
But my point was they were proposing to
fight in a fucking cage and somehow or
another it's just unbelievable outrage
because she made fun of her arms being
fat.
I know,
right.
We're going to read each other nearly to
death about fat
ass.
Yeah,
I mean is that really like,
can you can insult people about their
personality and the fact that there is
really what it is to.
First of all,
I encourage fat shaming.
I think it's helpful to you for real.
I really do.
I think it's.
I think it's absolutely helpful.
Why do you think it's helpful?
Because it depends on your psyche,
I guess.
You know,
how you respond to it,
but I think it's just like somebody
calling you out on your bullshit.
It's just a version of that is a
physical version of that and a lot of
people you can be in denial,
you know,
I think a lot of people are in denial
about a lot of things.
Well,
a lot of people just want to live their
lives to,
to take cheap,
to play devil's advocate,
right?
A lot of people just want to live their
lives and they don't mind being heavy.
They don't like it when people are
talking shit about something.
That's the choice,
you know?
I mean,
I'm not saying that that person doesn't
have a right to feel that way.
Right?
But it's what I think some people have a
problem with it is that these,
these,
there's certain people that didn't do
anything wrong.
They didn't do anything to you.
Everything they've done,
they've done to themselves.
Yeah.
But if you shitting on them,
it's kind of a,
it's an easy.
It's an easy thing to do.
It is an easy thing to do.
And uh,
you know,
if you weren't so fat,
nobody would talk about it.
So I mean,
I look,
I've been called fat at so many
different points.
I've been up and down my whole life,
so I feel,
I think because of that and when you get
older you have more acceptance with like
not having a problem with somebody
saying it.
People that I get,
I'm a public figure in a lot of ways,
right.
So I'm used to people being like,
fuck you,
and go fuck yourself.
I hate your act.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
It's another version of that.
Yeah.
Like you're fat.
And you're like,
it's a cue if you ain't feeling.
It's the same feeling as I'm saying
like,
I've gotten so much for that has nothing
to do with that.
If somebody throws in fat and you're
like,
yeah,
okay,
you know,
so weird.
I saw your special.
I fucking hated it.
Like,
okay,
susie.
Disappointed Bro.
Seriously,
you just appoint me disappointment.
Well,
all right.
Why?
Why did you disappoint this fight?
I mean,
it was,
you know,
I was just like,
I'm not going to engage you.
So it's bizarre when people do engage
people.
This,
we were talking about this before the
podcast.
Philly,
Philly d,
You know,
I'm from the Internet,
from a youtube.
Very nice guy.
Philip to Franco.
We've had them on the podcast for Super
Nice Guy.
Um,
he was going out with some chick.
He,
he tweeted something today.
What did it,
what was his original tweet?
Was it about Kanye or something like
that?
It's about visiting trump.
And he tweeted like,
trump would tweet.
Oh,
that's right.
He tweeted,
can't wait to see trump.
Tweet after this.
Met with Kanye West.
Tremendous American artists.
Shame Jay won't call him.
Pick up the phone.
Sad,
exclamation point because it's really
fucking funny.
That's really funny.
And uh,
some woman got really mad and liquid.
She wrote Mine Yo Damn White and stay
out of black people's beef.
You not a part of black twitter.
Stop stealing.
They're tweeting style.
And then I went to her page and I think
she's a troll.
I think she's,
I think she's trolling.
We don't have to give out her name or
anything like that.
Please don't get anybody excited.
Maybe she's real.
But maybe it's just felt like shitting
on them too.
Who knows?
Maybe she just felt like tighten it and
didn't think he was going to respond.
But he responded in a video.
Oh,
he did love his videos.
He responded and talked about and I was
like,
wow.
Weird.
Huh?
I love when people say like,
you're,
you're not to comment on this top on
this story,
right?
Like why not the best is that if you,
if you make any comment or joke about
anything political,
somebody who disagrees with that
political position will go,
we don't really need a comedian a
commenting on this.
And you're like,
oh,
okay.
What do you do?
Or are you the,
you're the person qualified to talk
about it.
Yeah.
How does that work?
So you work at the store,
the factory,
and you're allowed to comment on,
oh,
is that something that you would ever
say to anybody?
You're not allowed to comment on it.
Of course not.
That's so crazy.
Yeah,
I know.
It's,
it's absolutely hate these fucking white
people adding their two cents to Kanye
and Jay z saga.
Trying to get our t shut your God damn
mouth.
Always butting in.
She got us to talk about her job.
I mean this is the new world we're
living in.
Man Says you're not allowed to comment
on that because it's black beat.
She's saying,
well,
anybody telling you not allowed to
comment on anything.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Let me tell you something.
I have talked to people.
They have.
I have had the conversations with people
who think they're Kung Fu master could
fight in the UFC,
but everybody's scared of someone dying.
If someone understands real cheap,
real cheap master.
I've had these kinds of conversations
with people.
How much do people believe that Kung Fu
a lot of people still do?
Where do you think it would fall on the
scale of the martial arts?
Ability to win major fights with highly
trained people in either like where
would Kung Fu fall?
Well,
the problem with martial arts with
individual martial arts,
I ketos obviously at the top.
Yes,
but the problem is the problem with
individual martial arts like that is
that they're no longer unaware of the
tactics and abilities of other martial
arts,
so it used to be that if you were like a
taekwondo guy like I was,
you would have a delusional sense of how
good you would do in a fight with a judo
person because you don't because you've
never,
never.
Nobody grabbed me before and through
your round to really have no idea how
easy it would be for them to do it.
You have a distorted idea in your head.
Now everybody knows this guy.
Yeah.
Now everybody know.
So now it's real hard to say like a Kung
Fu guy.
Like if a Kung Fu guy fought a judo guy
who would win because there's no real
only Kung Fu guys anymore and there's no
real.
Only judo they'd have.
They all know about mma.
Yeah.
Everybody knows if you're a martial
artists,
especially your,
you know,
you get your black belt level or
something like that.
You're aware of other shit now,
so you,
you know what things,
you know what,
what's more effective now?
Like there's a better understanding of
it than anyone's ever had before.
So if you're like a high level martial
artists even arrest or something like
that,
I guarantee you they know.
Most of them know something else.
They know how to throw their hands.
They know how to throw a kicker too,
you know,
and if they got to like a really good
coach,
they could probably get pretty good at
striking.
Pretty fucking quit.
Sure.
But striking is one of those weird
things,
man.
It seems that it's really difficult to
people for people to get really good at
it.
If they don't have the right body for it
and they start late in life.
It's real weird.
Really.
Yay.
Yeah.
This,
you can get better at it,
but there's a certain amount of speed
that you need to execute really set up
in Knox and buddy.
There's a certain amount you can get by
with a certain amount of speed against
lesser competition.
You can get by even more so if you are
more of a threat as a wrestler and you
can give by even more.
So if you're really smart,
you really understand when to engage,
when not to engage and you're threatened
with arrest and you can get away with
like having a slower striking style,
but if you can't do those things then
you're a fucking sitting duck and that's
one of the most terrifying aspects of
them I met and the most terrifying
aspects of mma is being stuck in the
middle of the cage with a guy like
Anderson Silva and his prime.
It was just sliding slightly out of the
way.
Your Shit and crack and you in the face
and he's dancing around and you know,
he's making the wobbly face.
Like he's,
he's rocked.
Yeah.
To fuck with you.
And then he's kicks you and punches you.
Yeah.
He's done some creepy shit to dudes
inside the octagon.
I mean creepy in a way that's like not,
not negative.
I mean so good.
Like you said,
these moments in fights where you just
go,
holy shit,
it's creepy.
I do.
You got.
You get stuck in a cage with that dude.
He would just,
he just basically,
if this was a thousand years ago,
it would be that he would be the king of
the village like this.
Most likely now.
Well the village will be the biggest
guy.
See that.
What we're doing is we're separating
people by size.
True.
At the end of the day,
like if you meet a guy like brock
Lesnar,
you go,
oh,
that's why there's a heavyweight
division.
Right?
But that's a totally different kinds of
human.
How much,
how much?
How many guys like that can actually.
And I talking about brock specifically,
but that are like two 85 can move like
him.
Well No,
they can keep a body like that without
anything additional like.
In other words,
that's a super good question and it's
not anonymous question.
The problem is people are real dishonest
about what they take in,
what they don't take.
You know,
it's weird because there's people that
argue with you,
they'll say that there is only so big a
person can ever get and be so fast
without help.
Right?
But then he got to say,
but their understanding of recovery is
way better today than ever before.
Like your understanding of like when the
train would not train,
when you're overtrained,
like if you,
if you're at a real high level place,
they're going to like if you're grooming
you to be an nfl player or something
like that,
they're going to give you some
Pretty High Level Instruction and
coaching.
And if you're eating right,
you're going to have a definitely a jump
over people that were in your same sort
of position 20 years ago.
Right?
So the athletes are going to be better
just because of the science of training.
Sure.
But after that you gotta wonder.
Yeah.
I mean it's not like they don't know
about them.
Now of course they all know about
steroids.
So easy to get.
It's not like they don't know about them
and they not like they don't know.
They help.
And these dudes,
like some of the guys are definitely
fat,
right?
But some guys are like,
they're so like,
you're like,
you're walking around at like a healthy
three,
10.
Well,
I think some of them honestly are
probably a bit big on purpose to like
Lineman,
right?
You got to meet them.
Yeah.
You want to be a giant?
You want to be a giant monster shredded.
No,
no,
no.
You want to just went away a lot.
Matching into people.
I think the fuck do I know.
I know nothing about football.
You're totally right.
People say football players' names and I
have to not like a,
like a personal failing country.
Like um,
you know,
if someone's speaking to me in another
language,
like uh,
yeah,
I don't know what you're saying.
Yeah.
I feel like sports so to like I got you.
Oh yeah man.
But you know,
bay I wear hats a lot.
Especially I travel that.
I used to like having a hat on her plane
pull over and I have like 10 different
teams and guys were born and like you
see Douglas last night and I'm like,
what?
And they're like the game and I realized
it's the hat and I'm like,
I missed it.
He was like,
fuck,
shout them out.
Like fucking killer man.
Yeah,
I have no.
Ideally talking about,
well now there's so many UFC fighters,
there's like 500 UFC fighters occasion.
Like I got to look people up.
Sure.
Someone will mention some of them,
like who did he fight?
And they'll fight.
He fought that guy I'm like,
were like four fight nights ago.
My undercard were one was on the ground.
Like,
yeah,
I'll have to like my super big.
Too many fights have massive.
Has it gotten just in the time that I've
known or been to UFC stuff,
you know,
the fight game has exploded in
popularity.
It seems like,
um,
it all took off from this one fight in
2005 between Stephan Bonner and forrest
griffin.
That was like the big one because it was
the end of this,
the final of this first reality show,
the ultimate fighter.
It's crazy.
Fight in the finals and these guys knew
each other real well and they actually
liked each other a lot,
but they fucking went,
had it.
They just both went at it.
It changed the game.
Both guys fought Anderson Silva to.
Oh Wow.
Later in their career,
they both,
they both got fucked up now was when
they understand was just a jet.
I night he was just doing shit to people
inside the octagon where you're like,
oh Jesus.
How was that the um,
what was that?
That one fight with him.
Which one?
I think was it the Weidman One?
Oh,
he broke his leg or when the,
uh,
when you get knocked out.
I think when he got knocked out
probably.
And you've been to a ton of,
into a bunch of them now.
That one was crazy because he was
winning that fight.
If I didn't go to that one,
I definitely saw.
I've seen both those guys fight at
fights,
so I can't remember if I saw that fight
or not.
Weidman was pressing him,
but Anderson was kicking them a lot in
the legs.
Yeah.
And I was looking at,
I was like,
Ooh,
like he's,
he's kicking his legs a lot.
I hear a lot of time,
like crazy taunting.
But you know what?
Weidman did something really slick.
He did something really slick.
It's really interesting.
He threw a back fist.
He threw a punch and then he threw a
back fist because they understand what's
going on.
He was bobbing and weaving and bobbing
and weaving,
like moving away from.
So he figures if the rights come and
then the comment,
so he throws a punch.
Mrs then throws it back fist,
which makes Anderson have to go that
way.
Right.
So then when he starts going that way
the other way and catches him with a
left hook,
it's a.
it's a beautiful combination.
It's a beautiful combination with the
guy moves his head a lot because you
force them because you're not just
throwing one in that direction.
You throw in a second one,
so he's going that way,
which is like when you throw a left
hook,
he's going that way.
So He's already going the way to avoid
the left hook.
He's got to come back and when it comes
to when it comes back,
boom.
He catches him.
Perfect.
It was like,
it's brilliant.
You had a full time.
It's the setup before the fucking blow
to.
It looked a little slower than Anderson,
so he was having a hard time catching
them and they understand was staying on
the outside and kicking his legs a lot,
but they had collided in the first round
and he took anderson down and wrapped
one of his legs up and had them pretty
tight.
You might be getting a leg lock or
attempting to leg lock and Anderson got
out of it.
Isn't that different to where at the.
After the fight we're Weidman was like,
make your decision now you're either on
board or you're not.
I think there was no,
that was another fight.
Another fight.
Yeah.
I think that was,
um,
that was after Vittorio sick.
After he beat up beat tour.
He's like,
pick your title.
Yeah.
I was like,
well,
I'm bored.
I was like,
Damn Chris,
you've had up to now to decide.
Pretty good.
Yeah.
You know,
he's an interesting guy.
He takes a loss like a fucking champ.
I'll tell you that he lost to Yoel
Romero by knockout and the new sitting
on the das entering questions later with
this aisle stitched up.
Know what I mean?
He's,
uh,
he's a,
he's a stud.
You don't fight.
I was hard to do,
man.
Oh,
I bet.
Kao.
And then just answer,
answer questions with stitches over your
eye and you're talking to press people.
I've seen some guys real fucked up at
perfect composure though.
You handled it perfectly.
That was at that Gustafson,
Jon Jones fight where they,
I think they both went to the hospital.
[inaudible] brutal Dan Rudel.
Brutal fight.
It was a decision find,
I think.
Yeah.
Then it was like the,
like they just massacred each other,
you know,
they're just beat the shit out of each
other.
That was a crazy fight.
Yeah.
Does a fight where John was talking
about it when he was on the podcast.
We were talking about how much partied
after that fight for the fight.
Partying a lot.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was an incredible fight.
I just remember
how bloodied those guys were.
Yeah.
It was a rough fight and gustafson
shocked.
A lot of people.
That's the crowd.
You could feel the crowd swell.
What I always call mma,
this is the phrase I use all the time.
So maybe it'll start getting annoying
to.
It's like extreme problem solving with
dire physical consequences.
That's why it's a plus shit-talking
right?
Throwing that to stakes.
Talking Shit.
Yeah,
high stakes.
There's an emotional battle whether or
not you can keep your emotions.
How will you handle pressure this giant.
The thing about conor mcgregor more than
anything,
it's like,
no,
we shouldn't do more than anything.
It's one of many things about them
that's pretty interesting.
Well,
one of the most interesting things about
him as he handles pressure,
like nobody I've ever seen.
Yeah.
Like when he fought Aldo for the title,
he didn't even look remotely nervous.
He was super relaxed,
super calm.
But then you started to think though
that you go,
how much of what you're seeing is how
pressure is manifested through that guy.
You know what I mean?
Like for instance,
the press conference kind of antics.
You're like,
is that,
is that genuine?
Is that an act?
Is that how he handles the pressure of
this high pressure situation by doing a
fucking,
you know,
Bang,
Bang show at the time.
So like it.
But I personally,
I find the guy,
which is,
I think what you want,
why someone becomes a star,
a endlessly entertaining on top of being
good.
So I,
you know,
I'm tuning into,
I want to see the fucking show.
He's the best shit talker of all time.
I don't know.
I've said that before about other people
before that I said Chael Sonnen was the
best shit talker of all time and I think
he was for awhile,
but I think connor,
connor,
them and also sudden all also as well.
Connor has an additional significance to
a shit talking because he knocked people
dead.
Right?
It's a totally different thing.
And Chael Sonnen,
not that he's not a fucking animal
because Chael Sonnen is an animal and
he's.
He's submitted Shogun who a shell.
Simon's a very solid grappler came very
close to beating Anderson Silva in their
first fight.
So He's a stud.
But what connor does differently is the
isis guys with one punch.
And that's a big factor in the fight
when you're watching him and he fights
Eddie Alvarez and all of a sudden he
things and with the lefthand and catches
them in some early on you go holy Shit.
And they realize like he's fighting a
guy now at 155 pounds and Eddie Alvarez
a big one,
55.
He's a big guy,
big muscular guy.
The idea is he's going to be able to
wrestle connor.
He's going to be able to grab them and
grind them out the same way you did with
Anthony Pettis.
Nope.
Dealing with a totally different animal.
Connor's just got a totally different
kinds of focus as far as like the way
zooms in on targets and his precision.
It's just speed.
He's just dropping it in there with 100
percent speed.
Like that's a big part of what he's
doing.
He's not loading up at all.
And the ability to stay calm when you
load up,
say like if you see someone coming at
you and you just go like,
all that's wasted time that's wasted
time with connor has,
is the ability to be perfectly technical
in a firefight.
So like all those.
Yeah.
Charging Adam,
this is like 13 seconds into the fight.
All those charge and Adam and he knows
how to just slide back and blam drops
that lefthanded in on it is a striking,
the strongest part of his.
Yes,
for sure.
His ground game is underrated.
He's very good on the ground.
It was very good defensively.
He's got a good sweep sweep.
Nate Diaz,
their first pipe.
People forget that.
He's the kind of guy.
How much would you love to watch before
he was a professional?
I did watch them before know bar fights
though.
Oh Geez.
You know,
he's been in some definite scraps in
bars,
but I don't think you're allowed to
like,
get 18 in Ireland if you haven't been in
a bar fight.
Yeah,
we're going out tonight loud,
chatty.
That's probably the worst accident ever.
Probably right up there.
But um,
I saw him fight in a cage warriors.
I tweeted to him in like 2013 before he
came to the UFC.
I said,
I'm a big fan man.
Want you to come over and diddy?
Yeah,
I mean,
like,
right after that,
um,
the uh,
UFC in him.
Totally coincidentally,
I didn't cry.
I mean,
I definitely probably told anybody
listened to me about them because I had
seen him fight before.
I'm like,
this kid.
Isis people.
Yeah.
His left hand is just devastating and
he's got a crazy style.
He fights in his like wide stance and he
moves different and he cracks guys.
I'm like,
this kid's legit.
I'd like to see them in the UFC.
I never asked you.
Um,
yeah,
that's January of 2013.
So it was almost four years ago.
Did you,
did you think,
I didn't,
I never talked to you about what did you
think of all the,
um,
you know,
the talks of a him floyd mayweather
fight.
We'll fight them.
I guarantee you he would fight if you
think.
What kind of match do you think that
he's a lot bigger than floyd.
First of all,
let's,
let's just emphasize that.
Yeah,
he's a lot bigger,
so it'd be a real problem as far as like
weight cutting because if they were
layla conor fight at wherever he wants,
Connor's going away somewhere around 170
pounds.
Right.
That's where he's at.
His best like in is optima with no
weight cutting.
Yeah.
I don't think Floyd's that big.
I think floyd,
I guarantee you he's probably not more
than one 60.
Do you think floyd's bigger than one
slash 16.
Real life.
Small Dude.
He's a small guy.
Yeah,
he's really short.
Doesn't mean wait,
but he's small.
What weight did he begin?
His career at?
Floyd mayweather is mean.
I'm a huge flood bay with her fence and
I think that when it comes to boxing,
I think he's like one of the most
skillful boxers that's ever lived.
I really do technical,
if not the most 1:50.
But uh,
that's probably what he last fought at.
Like didn't he make 'em when he met?
When he fought Canelo didn't you make
him come down a bit and made him come
down to like 1:54
or something like that?
That sounds right.
Something like that.
I thought they had some sort of a catch
weight fight.
I remember Canelo's fight.
Nobody's finding
one 60 now.
He's definitely bigger.
Or is he fighting at 1:54?
Gennady Golovkin is one 60,
right?
Is that the hold up is the two of them
because I think I feel like Canelo has
been fighting midway too.
Like he fought cotto.
What was that?
That wasn't that at middleweight or
1:54.
Alvarez.
Alvarez catch weight 1:50
1:52.
Okay.
Yeah.
So he made canelo loose some weight.
He just Canelo is a lot bigger than him.
Yeah.
So canal probably walks around maybe 20
pounds heavier than that.
That's a bad motherfucker too.
He's good.
Yeah.
And for me,
that just boxed him up yet what?
That's there.
I'm hearing plot.
Oh look at that.
Just beautiful technique.
That's the thing you have to wonder
could,
uh,
is,
is like connor's skills,
technical skills match up to somebody
like the counter counter defense,
you know,
I can't imagine they would unless
mayweather.
So out of shape.
Yeah.
I'm staying on top of his game.
Him on top of his game.
You're not going to hit him.
He's going to know.
I mean you have to be really top level
to catch him.
It's so nuts at.
That dude is so fast that he,
he box it like something nobody has done
with his lead hand down.
Not even hip level.
Mid Thigh Times.
Well let's,
because that forces his shoulder over.
It's actually an easier way to block a
lot of things if you're skillful with
it.
Got shoulder roll.
Yeah.
You got to be.
It's not just quick and he's definitely
quick.
It's very quick.
But what floyd has over like almost
anyone else,
he said he's got this incredible
knowledge of what you're going to do
before you do it.
Like he knows so much about boxing,
about boxing as a science from his
brother or his father rather,
and his uncle,
his uncle's roger made,
whether it was a black Mamba who was an
all time fucking exciting guy to watch.
And like the eighties and nineties,
he would starch people,
man
sued him on those Hbo shows.
They've never had a better comedy than
Roger May.
Whether moments.
It's the greatest.
Oh,
you mean in between corners?
No,
when they used to do the 24 slash seven,
24 slash seven,
he would fucking massacre those,
like the funniest shit I've ever seen.
And they edited it to him.
So fucking funny.
One of those fights they were fighting,
maybe it was Alvarez or somebody and I
was like,
we've got to prepare for Florida and
watch his fights and uh,
and I'm just,
I know I'm just going to have the fight
in my life,
in my hands.
And then they cut to Roy or to,
to Roger May,
whether he goes,
who the fuck is Albert?
Like he was pretending he doesn't even
know who the guy.
But that really was,
you know,
that that was a big part of the
preparation for.
I don't know if it in the end it was,
but for a long time when they would go,
like,
how are you preparing for this fighter?
His,
his answer and they're legit answer was
like they have to prepare for this
shit.
Yeah.
We're not preparing for anything.
He better prepare a lot,
you know?
And that's how they would approach it.
Like,
we're not studying you.
You need to study this shit right now
because it's going to be bad.
What happens to you?
It's,
yeah,
it's a good point.
You know,
Floyd's an interesting guy.
He's had his hands broken a bunch of
times.
Yeah.
Is.
There's been rumors about fights that he
must have had a broken hand in.
Oh,
he has had hands that were broken and
he's still boxed that.
What does that feel like?
As soon as got a winner's mentality,
you know,
you can talk all the shit you want about
that guy because it's fun to talk shit
about him because you've created this
persona.
Mayweather.
But it's brilliant.
It's a brilliant thing.
What he did is brilliant.
He created like someone to hate,
but it's so talented.
You can't be them and you're buying that
pay per view,
which is exactly what you want.
You're hoping that it.
Oh,
please.
Canada.
They're hoping Canelo can catch them.
They're hooking pack yogurt up everyone.
Yeah.
You're the guy that he created the
villain.
Keep going down the line.
Every fucking guy he's fought.
Please catch them.
Maybe you know you.
You saw what one way Marquez.
He had a tough fight with Pacquiao.
Shuts them down overnight and then he'd
be like,
I got 100 watches man.
And then that shuts them all down.
People like they really fucking.
I don't hate at all.
I think that it's a.
sometimes that persona can just get kind
of boring.
It's fun.
Smart is it?
I'm like,
all right man,
just that I'm saying like instagram,
he's like,
look at all this money on my bed and
he'll be like,
no,
I'm going to count it.
Hilarious.
It's funny,
it's entertaining,
but it is like one note he used to hold
like bricks and money up to his ear
phone.
Pretend he's talking on the money.
Larry cars like exactly ridiculous.
They're all white too.
He's got like bugattis and shit.
Three Jesus Christ.
Oh my goodness.
What is that $100,000,000
that he got from what?
It was just purse from one of his
fights.
He was a promoter.
He made a $100.
Million Dollars.
Yeah,
we're hip hippy.
Start going crazy.
But income inequality,
there's a sense.
Look at it as he goes.
This is just one of my many checks.
GotTa love these backseat drivers,
so worried about hipaa school.
Where are you going?
Yeah.
Got To love these backseat drivers,
so worried about another man's legacy
instead of trying to write their own.
Ultimately I will always have the last
laugh.
This is just one of many checks.
Oh,
cool.
$100.
Million dollars that I still have.
Every dime of y'all still have to work.
However,
I'm happily retired.
At the end of the day,
it's them.
Benjamin Franklin does matter to me.
So the joke's on you.
I've made smart investments.
Sorry for those who thought that I
couldn't read,
write or count.
Here we go.
Y'All call them watches,
I call them time pieces.
You all call them bullets.
I call them odds.
You'll call them houses.
I call them match.
What?
What does that mean?
You all chartered jets and we own jets.
The money team and you go,
hmm.
Yeah,
I got it.
I think he's rich.
I think he definitely has money,
so he's made a lot of fucking money,
that's for damn sure.
He's excellent at what he does for sure.
Across the board.
Yeah.
I mean there's no doubt about it,
but he's also funny.
He's 49.
Yeah,
40 9:11
and he's the only guy.
He said he hasn't broken rocky
Marciano's record yet.
He's tied it,
which is really interesting.
Like I wonder if that's on purpose.
I wonder if he doesn't want to break it.
Well,
I think there's lot people talking shit
about the pressure of it,
of a,
of it going away is the thing that
happens.
Like as the older you get,
like,
you know what I mean?
This is,
this is a good boxing retirement age for
him.
It's like,
do you want to do 50?
Yes.
Well,
it's got to be a meaningful 50.
You can't reach them.
Scrub for 50 and then you start to think
about,
oh fuck.
Like,
yeah,
if he was gonna Fight Pacquiao again,
I wonder what kind of.
I'm sort of out of the loop.
I wonder what kind of numbers pack y'all
gets on his fights now.
A lot of people are watching.
I'm sure he's still the last one I
think.
But he just fought.
He did just fight.
Yeah.
I didn't hear any peep about it.
Yeah,
but who was he fighting that?
Maybe that's why he still does.
I mean,
it's got to be significant numbers
still.
Yeah,
he must.
Right.
So that's still a big worthwhile fight.
Oh yeah.
He's got a big bankroll apparent.
I mean payroll like apparently you this
pack,
yell,
Vargas fight surpassed 300,000
pay.
If view buys his pack,
Y'all made whether to possible that's
decent.
Those are decent pay per view buys
300,000.
That's pretty good.
What did the big fights like?
Big MMA fights get?
Uh,
the big ones are over a million.
I think I probably the UFC,
I don't know if it's been released yet.
What ufc a 200 got or UFC 205.
Either one of those.
Madison Square Garden was a pretty
fucking substantial card.
Automatically.
The numbers of that would have been
insane and it was a conor mcgregor card.
I wouldn't have to think that that's the
biggest card ever.
Ever terms of pay per view buys?
Yeah,
I would imagine,
but I could be wrong because a 200 ad
brock lesnar in it.
Oh yeah.
You know,
and that,
that ended badly a few days later to
right.
Wasn't there couple wasn't badly rose.
Just just something that I've gotten
this fruit punch bro.
Or drank a lot of fruit,
Bruh.
Yeah.
You never know man.
Cell phone minutes.
Yeah.
That's what we were talking about.
Sure.
Can that guy get that big without some
help?
I don't know.
I do not know.
I do not know,
but I know those GNC stores,
they do really well.
I saw a lot of stuff.
He can go to those places.
They sell a lot of stuff in any of those
bodybuilding supplement stores.
You know,
you could,
there's a lot of stuff that works,
like there's a reason why people buy
that stuff,
but some of it is fucking steroids in it
and that's why it's working.
And they legit get away with that,
huh?
Well they just don't tell you what it
is.
Remember weird man,
like 15 years ago,
one of the first big,
I forget the product name or I would say
it,
it was like the big,
like everyone does this to workout and
to lose weight.
I forget.
It's like it had a big commercial,
the,
it was a successful name for the product
and then people just started to drop
would die and it wouldn't become like
many years ago you're talking about,
I think it's about 15 to 20.
She talking about rip fuel one of those
[inaudible] right?
Right.
But I pedron rather federal,
federal.
And then people were.
I remember I was taking them 20 some
years ago as a 20th day.
No,
but,
but then somebody's like,
oh,
you're basically,
you're taking speed.
And you're like,
oh.
And it took a while to process that
really was one of the key components of
what you were taking.
Like you're taking drugs right now,
maybe taking speed,
so you're taking speed and you could
feel yourself get geeked out,
you know,
heart racing.
I took a couple of those and want to do
Jitsu class once when I was like a white
belt and almost had a fucking heart
attack.
The heart rate.
Oh my God,
I have stopped.
I sit down.
I was like,
what did I do?
Yeah.
So I was young.
I was just starting in Jujitsu and it
wasn't like.
I mean I knew what it felt like to roll,
but I,
you know,
when you,
when you take those,
I was like,
I knew something was totally wrong.
Yeah.
So like I had been exhausted before.
I know what that felt like.
Yeah.
I got exhausted way too quick.
My heart was about to explode in my
fucking chest.
So I was like,
Holy Shit.
I got to sit down.
Like even being like whatever I was 30
or whatever,
29 or something like that.
I still was smart enough to realize this
is a stupid idea and I got to sit down.
Back then I was really dumb.
I took a minute before high school
football game.
Yeah,
but the thing is that we had the
conversation before.
They're like,
you're going to fuck people up because
of this,
so you have the illusion of what's going
on.
Well maybe that would work though with
football,
because football is not something you
would do where you struggle for long
periods of time.
You get like,
it's like five,
six,
seven.
You Jitsu gets super exhausting.
Sure.
Because like say if you have a sparring
rounds,
they might be seven minutes long.
Sometimes people do nine minutes.
Yeah,
that sounds really seven minutes was
pretty standard and so we'd set a timer
for seven minutes and then you're
basically just going at it with someone
who is probably pretty fucking skillful.
Yeah.
You're going to die.
You feel like.
Like I felt like my heart was literally
gonna Explode.
Like something's wrong.
Like it was like,
dude,
we're going away too fast right now for
no fucking reason.
Like man,
I got to sit down and my heart wouldn't
start.
It wouldn't slow down.
It wouldn't.
Like normally when you work out you have
like safety run up a hill and you put
your fingers on your pulse and you can
sit there and then a few seconds you
feel him start to drop and you look down
at your watch and when you get to like
1:40
ish,
you could just start sprinting again.
Right.
That's what most people like to share
when you're doing like interval
workouts.
I knew I was way over that and I wasn't
coming down.
I was like,
this is not slowing down.
Like this is fucked.
And you knew that's what you took.
I know I took a bunch.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a fucking retard.
I'm such an extremist.
If it says like take two.
I'm like,
that's too for pussies.
So take for stupid man because you know.
Yeah.
Well it was like,
like doing the competitive martial arts
thing when I was young made me like this
intense extremist.
Sure.
Like A.
Okay.
Everybody's running two miles.
I'm running five.
You know,
everybody's doing this.
I'm doing more,
or is that how you do it?
Really?
There's no other way.
If you want to beat people,
you have to be.
You have to work harder than them.
I'm sure you can't just rely on what
you're smarter than them.
How do you know you're smarter than
them?
They're probably pretty fucking smart.
What are you're tougher than them?
They're tough.
No fucking black belts.
Like don't be stupid.
Like my thought was,
I don't think so highly of yourself that
you don't have to outwork everybody.
Wow,
that's good,
man.
That's a good philosophy and you can't
take days off.
Days off if you're hurt or if you're
sore.
He can't fuck off.
Fucking off is bad for your brain.
It's like if you have a.
If you're competing or you're trying to
go for something like physically fucking
problem with fucking off is that it
messes with your momentum.
It's not just that it messes with your
skills because sometimes you
legitimately go,
you know what?
My body needs a break yet,
but you know,
your body needs a break so you make a
conscious decision,
but when you were supposed to work out,
you know you should work out and you
fuck off.
You're just like your opinion of
yourself slips.
Exactly.
It has.
It has an effect that goes out beyond
just that workout.
Yeah.
It fucks with your confidence because it
fucks with your conviction.
It's why taking care of,
of little things can bleed into taking
care of.
You know what I mean?
Like when you go like pick up and clean
up your room,
you know,
car you're like,
now I feel good about the way this
looks,
that translate.
I'm going to go work out today and I'm
going to write.
I'm going to do it.
Like those things kind of line up
together.
Yeah.
Musashi had some quote about that that I
just a screenshot at the other day,
like a 15 year old girl.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's me.
I'm one of those screenshot guys.
Don't you know if you've read here it is
because it's just so interesting to
approach or the approach to combat and
everyday life should be the same.
The Oh,
well that's,
that's a nice approach to combat and
everyday life should be the same.
That's,
that's intense.
Yeah.
It was a little too intense.
I have a real interesting one on my
instagram.
I don't know if you can pull it up.
Is that the guy who touched the girl for
the first time?
That video?
No,
but uh,
it is a lady with a holiday one,
but it's interesting.
Yeah.
Who is that guy that touched the girl?
Did you get permission to put them on
your part?
To take on that one that you made me put
up?
The Christmas one?
Yeah.
That one's pretty interesting.
The one where the girl,
the one that you.
Oh,
when you.
Whoa.
It up for Eczema.
So I mean,
it's interesting.
Watch it.
Okay.
What,
what
are you doing,
man?
What is wrong with you and your wife?
First of all,
you're both fucking hilarious chisels,
but specific.
Yeah.
You have the.
You guys have the funniest,
silliest fucking show because you're
both so specific things,
the things that you just decide like
you're wearing a shirt.
Tom's wearing a shirt that says just
glass and on it now glass is a term that
hunters used when they get up on a ridge
and they look for things.
So when I saw that,
I was like,
well that's weird.
Like what did you.
Maybe you bought that convenience store
when we were in Alaska or something like
that.
Yeah.
This would be a silly gimmicky shirt
toy,
but no,
this is a shirt like from your fucking
podcast.
It is,
yeah.
It's a tell the story because every week
we get submitted hundreds of emails with
links to videos like that.
Right,
right.
I mean,
so many emails.
Have you seen this?
Have you seen the and the.
And the Internet is endless pool of
stuff to pull from.
And then we have this,
our producer blue band,
I don't know if you know that.
That's our producer's name.
The band.
Yeah,
because it used to be red band.
There was a yellow band for awhile and
now there's blue band,
so,
so blue band.
Then we'll go through a lot of this
stuff and edit down,
let's say like a five minute youtube
video until like maybe six,
10 to 15 second clips.
So we're just always looking at stuff
and it's,
you know,
the,
like,
uh,
a range of things are engaging to us.
When we got this hunter,
his name is Fred Eichler.
I think he's an avid bowhunter.
He bumped he bonds with a traditional
bow,
like a recurve bow.
That's right.
The one of the most prominent,
a recurve bow hunter.
It's either a recurve bow or it might be
a stick bow.
What is the difference between a recurve
bow versus what you power,
power accuracy,
efficiency technology.
Yours is more modern.
Yeah.
But in his side feel there's like a feel
and if you get really good with one of
those things,
it becomes apparently very addicted to
shoot because,
uh,
like people who like recurves,
they like shooting at targets.
It's an instinctive thing.
Okay.
So you have to shoot a bunch of arrows
to kind of know where the Arrow is going
and he shoot differently too because you
don't really hold it very long.
You got,
you kind of draw it back and then they
let it go pretty quickly.
Whereas a compound bow,
the whole idea of a compound bows,
there's an extreme amount of force
that's exhibited in the beginning or
it's expressed through this campaign and
through the limbs.
But then as a camp turns over,
it gets easier because of leverage.
So I don't remember the resistance
starts when you kind of start at the
beginning,
there's massive resistance and then
there's a big lead off at the end.
So like my boat takes 84 pounds to pull
back,
but
at the end of it it's easy to hold and
wouldn't have it.
What's the different?
His would go hard the whole way is hard
the whole way,
however hard it is,
it's hard the whole way and it actually
gets more difficult as you pull back
instead of less difficult.
Wow.
So it's the opposite of a compound bow.
So the compound bows,
it's difficult to pull in the beginning
and then the camp settle in.
Oops.
The Cam settle in.
It's beautiful.
You can just hold it there.
Like if you're waiting on something you
could hold it there because it's just
super hard to hold one of those stick
bows because you're pulling the end of
it is as hard as you can get it,
you know,
and it's basically,
it pulls back and forth depending upon
like how much pressure you put on it.
You can pull it more if you're stronger
or if you're weaker,
you can only get to a certain point.
It sounds like if the train to shoot
with this thing,
well it depends on now most of the time
no because most of them are fairly weak.
But like um,
you can make them like really powerful.
You can make them.
I mean if you had a recurve bow and
particularly the Mongols apparently
according to Dan Carlin,
that hardcore history guy who's awesome,
he said their bows were 160 pounds to
pull back.
Woo.
Which is crazy.
Yeah,
I mean it's like doing,
that's,
that's so like,
it's what you're essentially doing is
you're doing like an 80 pound push and
an 80 pound pole until the same time.
It's a lot to be able to do that a lot
of times in a row.
It's way harder than doing that with a
compound bow because a compound,
but it's just a little difficult and
then easy.
And this is who would have these 160
pounds.
The Mongols did Mongo,
this is,
you know,
12 hundreds somewhere around then they,
that was technology back then because
they figured out what a recurve bows.
It's crazy bow that,
uh,
the way it's designed,
if you see a recurve,
both that's not strong,
it doesn't even look like it would work.
Like if you're seen what they look like,
I saw it in this guy's video.
Yeah.
This Fred Eichler guy probably,
I don't even think he had a recurve bow
on this.
I think he,
I think he shoots with what they call a
stick bow,
which is the most prevalent I think I
read in his bio recurve could be a
recurve.
I bet he's got a bunch of different
ones.
Yeah.
White Buffalo recurves that what he
shoots with.
Okay.
See if you can show a picture of one
without the string.
Um,
because they're,
they're so weird looking or you know,
what,
just see if you could find a picture of
the Mongol Bose because those are the
first ones.
I think somewhere in that time of the,
of the world was the first ones when
people had figured out how to make a
recurve bow.
See that's what the top ones,
what looks like without the string and
it's going to go back to the shape where
you see in the bottom right in the same
position.
So it is.
So it's totally bent the other way.
So because of that it stores up all this
extra energy because it's your polling
so far back and it has this tremendous
snapping effect when you let go of the
string.
Hmm.
It's pretty dope.
They,
I mean they,
they are incredibly smart for figuring
this out and then to make them
unbelievably tough.
See,
that's what it looks like on the strong.
Yeah.
And make them so tough that you can pull
it all the way back the other way.
Like they had to figure this shit out.
So they had to use a bunch of different
materials that comes out with incredible
for us.
Yeah.
That's still not as fast as probably a
modern day compound bow and also not
that consistent because they didn't have
scales.
Their arrows,
the arrows are all probably very
inconsistent because you're like,
you're making your own broadheads.
Some of them might be a little heavier
than others.
The factory mass producing them.
Yeah.
Now they're making arrows that are like
aluminum and carbon fiber cores and they
have like a very like,
you know,
you buy these arrows from like eastern
or one of the top level companies that
made arrows.
They have like this super high tolerance
levels for like each,
each,
each one of the arrows that leaves their
factory there super straight like spin
him and shit and make sure that
everything's good.
Yeah.
No,
it's a totally.
It's incredible how that,
that technology evolved.
Yeah.
So there's a lot of these guys like this
guy you're talking about the glass and
guy,
he still uses like one of those
primitive boasts,
but he's just so good.
He can get away with it.
It says.
I mean there's bio is incredible,
but in this video it starts with him.
Uh,
he,
he shoots a moose and it drops quick and
he fucking comes close to coming in his
pants.
Like he,
he makes a sound that you don't even,
you can't.
He goes like,
like,
like can you show it to us?
Uh,
yeah.
Are you allowed to play it online?
Did you get pulled from anything?
No.
Playing on Youtube,
no.
And,
and we also play,
I mean the audio is,
is what's incredible,
but then he starts talking about glass
in and he's like,
we were just coming around meadow glass
and glass and we were like,
let's go,
let's glass.
And he goes,
keeps going.
Glass,
glass,
glass and glass,
which is looking through binoculars,
which we discovered,
but then we played it so much.
People like I would post a picture of
myself like I'm about to go on stage and
they're like,
are you glassing and,
or you know,
like if you talk to somebody like,
what'd you do today?
Like Oh,
I hung out and they're like glass and
you're like,
yeah.
So then it morphed into meaning,
like,
just chill.
Yeah.
And I don't know,
it just kind of picked up from there.
You guys have so many of these though.
I would have to ask you.
Okay.
What's the deal with jeans calling
everybody jeans.
Like when you guys were on that and you
had explained it to me.
Yeah.
The latest thing is with that first we
had an electrician over at the house and
whenever you're in the house,
you know your call your spouse,
I'd be like Jane's Dino,
because that's what I call her.
So then she walked down the stairs and
he goes,
gene,
would you like me to put the heat?
And we just let it go.
We called her jeans,
but then we started going into starbucks
and ordering our drinks.
It's just like a stupid thing like that.
We told our listeners,
we do,
we do this regularly just to amuse
ourselves,
which is we'll call them jeans and then
say thank you mom,
your I love you mommy at the end and no
one ever.
The order happens so fast and it's so
like programs that they never cashed.
Never say like,
what did you say?
So like when I,
when I pull up like,
welcome to starbucks.
What,
what can I get for you?
It'd be like a hey jeans,
I want to get an iced coffee,
extra ice and what?
You want a double tall.
So we're allowed to.
Okay.
That'll be 60,
70 words.
I'll.
I'm like thanks mommy.
And then I just pull up.
So we told them we did that.
People sent us videos of them doing it
fucking hilarious.
Like a guy like getting his uh,
he was talking to a bill play place and
he's like,
hey mommy,
I don't understand what this bill means.
And the other guy is like,
yeah.
So that first section,
like they don't even address that.
You're calling someone mommy or jeans or
saying thank you mommy or I love you
mommy.
I'm like,
okay,
have a good day.
Like they just,
it speaks more to almost have
preprogrammed customer service becomes,
you know,
they're not even acknowledging that
you're saying something ridiculous to
them.
No,
no,
they're not.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
But also like,
what are you saying when someone says
something like that to you,
you'd probably like,
you're so scrambled.
I think so,
yeah.
Because it doesn't make any sense,
but started off not making any sense,
but then it picked up and made a lot of
sense.
So clearly you can talk English and then
it gets to the end.
He calls you mommy.
You're like,
whoa.
What happened?
One time we called the renaissance in
Cincinnati,
the hotel,
because the year before,
before,
a few months before my son was born,
we were there for a wedding and
Christina had like a 32nd fart.
So we,
she's very pregnant.
We came back and we talked about it and
we decided it deserved its own names.
What's called the Cincinnati Fart.
Oh Jesus.
And we figured out what room number we
were in and we called the hotel and I
go,
can I help you?
I want a book,
I want to stay there,
but I want to commemorate the Cincinnati
part.
And she goes,
I'm sorry,
what was that?
And I go,
I want to stay in this room.
I think it's from six one eight because
this has a fart happened there.
And she goes,
I just having a little trouble.
What was that?
The what?
And I'm like,
this Cincinnati Fart.
And she's like,
can you spell it for me?
And I go,
yeah,
f a R T.
and she stayed professional.
Like she was like,
oh,
okay,
I'll see what I can do it.
Yeah,
she didn't probably have cameras on you.
You can't go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Well,
I did have a,
uh,
a flooring guy.
I go,
can you do this floor for me?
And he's like,
oh,
I can send you some samples.
And I go,
great.
He goes,
who do I send it to?
I go to your mom's house.
And he was like,
what was that?
And I go,
your mom feeling.
He goes,
my mom's house.
I go,
no,
that's the name of our,
our company,
your mom's house.
And I go,
yeah.
And he was like,
alright,
you have a good day.
And he hung up the phone and I go like I
was,
I wasn't trying to frame.
It was a totally normal.
I wasn't funny.
I go,
no,
that's the name of the [inaudible]
didn't want to listen.
He was like,
okay,
okay.
You have a good day.
Like wow.
Okay.
Did you try.
You let them hang.
You should have said it's actually
the name of podcasts we,
it's called tried to explain it,
but he was look it up on itunes.
It's very popular.
He was,
he was pretty quick with like,
Oh,
this is a joke.
And I go,
okay.
He grew up with a lot of your mom jokes.
Yeah,
he did not lying it.
Not Buying.
It seems like a,
a guy that just didn't get it.
Can you play Fred?
Will you plays audio?
The glass guy?
Yeah.
It's.
Where do you have it on your phone?
It's on youtube.
Okay.
What is the name of the video?
It's called saved on his phone.
Tell you,
give me one moment.
I'll look.
Tom Segura at the ice house tonight.
Sold out.
I'm at.
I'm doing dahmer air show tonight.
And you're at the laugh factory
tomorrow.
Tomorrow?
Yeah.
With Duncan trussell and Tony
Hinchcliffe.
Dude.
Got a couple of Bop bop,
bop,
bop.
This should be it.
Okay.
Crank it up.
That looks like a compound bow.
Really.
Couldn't tell.
It was moving really quick.
Yeah,
that's a compound.
Will see the cameras at the top of the
bow.
That's not a permanent boat.
All that's super modern bow
I think,
but this suit knows how to do this.
He's like,
Oh yeah.
Know he's so professional or I've seen
this guy on tv a ton of time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's got a TV show that I watched.
Dude,
if you go over my house,
you think I'm a crazy person.
You change your profile pic.
Yeah.
It's a silly picture of me with a camera
on my face.
Hide in the trees.
I'm trying to make sure that this is the
right video.
I'm looking as we're going through the
trees.
Every once in a while I stopped,
but I can still see the moon through the
tree.
Blended in good.
When does it get good at archery?
Archery bows down.
Yeah.
That's coming up it.
Here we go.
Okay.
It's a bad thing.
Full shot.
Wait,
count.
Countdown to getting real funny.
I just smoked her.
She's got to watch her.
Watch her.
She's going to go down to her law.
Jesus,
I don't like this part.
I was raised out here.
Early boarding.
Look at the.
Look at the metal.
This is why.
This is why we came up here.
We'd been slipping along this big huge
meadow.
Big,
long,
tall metal.
We've been slipping along here.
Just glass and just glass and glass and
all of a sudden I didn't even have.
I didn't even put my headset on.
I'm like,
ah,
we're just glassing huge.
Let's just keep going.
Let's glass.
Let's look like holy smokes.
Like got a Moose Moose.
And I'm like,
Oh man,
it's a bowl.
It's a full.
I'm like,
no,
it's a cow.
The cow right there.
That was unbelievable.
We came right around this tree.
Is a cow more significant than a bowl?
No.
No,
unless he only had a tag for a cow.
Oh,
depends on why.
Why he shot a cow.
Not a,
not a bull.
Sometimes it depends on the unit.
It depends on how many cows they have
versus how many bowls they have.
They might want people to kill cows.
They probably want a certain amount of
cows to be killed a year.
They have weird.
Um,
who decides that fish and game
department,
they go to the.
We have too many heads entirely on where
you are.
Depends entirely on what part of the
world you're in.
And then do you report it?
Yep.
Yeah.
You tag a tag.
An animal.
Let me save you a,
you shoot a moose.
That's Moose.
This one I shot in British Columbia.
Really?
Yeah.
And you,
uh,
you have a tag and you take that,
you know,
you,
you have to pay for it.
And they allot a certain amount of,
um,
some places they have what's called over
the counter,
which means they just have,
it's just kind of open to anybody who
wants to pay for the hunting fee and pay
for the tag feet to some species.
Particularly.
Would you shoot that with.
That was with a rifle.
Really?
Yep.
Were you glassing before a glass in?
No,
that was like four solid days of hunting
with no luck.
And then we're literally driving down
this road and off the side of the road.
Seventy yards away was a moose.
It was so crazy.
It happened so fast.
We stopped the truck,
the Moose looked up.
He didn't know what we were.
I put a,
uh,
a shell.
I put a bullet in the chamber,
push the Bolt in,
took the safety off Saturday.
My Eye.
I'm like,
do I have time to lean against anything?
I didn't have time to lean against
anything.
I just held it up freehand because he
was only about 65 slash 70 yards away.
He was really close.
It was so close.
I knew I could make the shot and boom,
boom.
And then down immediately there was done
immediately.
So weird feeling,
man.
It's a weird feeling.
Like I,
I'll be honest,
I don't do what that guy does,
but I use part of you gets pumped,
party gets excited,
but I don't act like that guy seems
really little theatrical.
But I mean that's just,
I don't,
I'm not him personally,
but for him maybe that's just how we
react to it here.
He was very excited.
Very excited.
Yeah.
Which I understand it's not easy to do,
especially with a bow and arrow.
Very difficult to do.
It will say.
I do feel this thing.
I'm not an anti hunting guy at all to
like bad.
It's hard to watch the um,
the animal fall apart.
I don't like it.
Yeah.
It's hard to watch anything die.
So I'm fun and it's one of the problems
that we have with eating meat in this
country is that we don't watch the
animals dying.
Of course it totally affects you.
I went to a slaughterhouse,
wants me to,
and I was a teenager though.
Oh really?
Yeah.
How long does stop you from eating meat?
No few hours at,
but it still
was one of those images that you're
like,
fuck me.
We felt fear factor in the slaughter
house once and you could feel it.
You'd feel it in the building.
I mean,
maybe it's just my head.
Yeah,
but it didn't feel like it.
It felt like a dull hum of death
everywhere.
You were just like,
there was almost like an ambient sound
that you could pick up.
I remember the floors,
we had like rain boots on,
walk around and there's just like so
much fluid,
so much blood guts.
He was like a pieces of things,
you know?
Fuck man.
Yeah.
It makes you really understand what the
fuck you're looking at.
They would like it.
It definitely could deter you.
I mean I still,
I was like,
I was a young teenager and I still liked
me,
but I think I definitely would be harder
as I'm older.
What do you think.
This is something I've considered,
like do you think that if you took kids
at an early age to a slaughterhouse,
what percentage of them would continue
to eat meat?
You lose a significant number of them.
Right.
That's very interesting.
Yeah.
So children probably shouldn't be
exposed to something that horrific,
somewhat argued.
Right.
That's,
that's a good argument that maybe
children don't need to see an animal get
a piston through its head and getting
hung up by his ankles and he got it.
But guess what?
Kids who grow up on farms,
they see that shit through kids who grow
up in hunting families.
They see that shit and it doesn't seem
to be.
It doesn't seem to bother them that
much.
Yeah.
I think when kids don't see something
like that and then they see it,
then it really fucks them up.
But we,
um,
when we shot this elk in a to hone ranch
when they were taking the Elca part.
Yeah,
we were,
you know,
cutting the quarters off and doing all
this stuff.
This one guy,
his wife and his little girl came to
watch and one thing she said was this
elk was lying down on the ground dead.
She's like,
because he's the P.
Yeah.
And she's like two.
And she's a tiny little girl.
She's probably barely talking.
She's like,
is he sleepy?
And the mom was like,
no,
he's dead.
She told her.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can change your perspective if you
do what you do for sure.
If you kill and eat what you killed.
I think that changed your perspective on
it.
Well,
I don't think people have to do it.
I'm not one of those people that think
that people have to do,
but I do.
But it changes you a little bit.
Right.
When you remember that,
like you did this and then you used it
to meet for something.
It's totally different.
It's a totally different feel when you
eat it.
Like,
and I'm not one of those people that
doesn't think you should be able to get
me to the supermarket.
I think you should,
but I think there's,
there's definitely something weird about
not knowing how that animal died.
Yeah.
Like that's not normal,
right?
It's like our,
our brains,
the way we formulate ideas a lot of is
based around experience.
Right?
And the experience,
like if you're eating a piece of meat or
if you're even eating fruits or
vegetables for that matter,
you will understand that experience
better if you go through the whole
process,
like if you're there when the plants are
growing,
maybe help water them,
maybe pick them,
maybe cut them up and serve them,
and then you're eating them.
Having a garden is fucking cool thing.
It's a cool thing.
It gives you some weird thankfulness,
which I think is one of the things
that's a problem with people today is
that things come so easy to us that we
don't have obstacles to overcome and
we're not super thankful for the super
easy life that we have.
Totally.
We think of it as being like,
yeah,
it's just what it is,
man.
Traveling somewhere poor.
We'll give you a perspective on that for
sure.
Oh,
I imagine.
Yeah.
Go into like a really poor place.
You'll,
you'll definitely rethink,
uh,
you know,
calling over the waiter.
Jamie,
who was it that was telling us.
Yeah.
Who was it that was telling us that they
landed in the Congo and they were in
the,
uh,
they landed in the wrong spot.
Who the fuck was that?
Was that Tom?
Papa?
It might've been Tom.
Papa.
It was Tom.
Yes.
Emergency lanes.
Yeah,
they're fucking their balloon.
They went up in a balloon like asshole.
Tom Pop is awesome.
He's really funny.
He's a funny dude.
He's great on podcast too,
man.
He sits like a,
an elegant dance partner conversation.
You're totally right.
Yeah.
But he's got an amazing story about how
they were up in this building.
It was Tom Papa his live show anyway.
Totally sure.
Have you done any live show his live
show?
What is it?
Tom Poppin and friends.
Was it a state a podcast?
It,
no,
it's a live scripted to like,
um,
like a 19 thirties radio show.
Yeah.
And he'll be like,
out of Largo.
No,
Shit.
It's fucking fun.
I've been on it a few times and he'll
like,
what he does is he'll comes out,
there's a fucking band that plays,
like throwback,
you know,
kind of music.
And then he hosts it like a radio show.
So.
And then there's a theme,
there's stories and inbetween these
sketches with live actors like you,
you have a script and you read in front
of an audience stand up in between.
Does he have his own podcast?
Yeah,
I think so.
What does Tom Papa's podcast for sure.
How do I not know this answer?
Because I knew.
Do you use to do one with somebody?
He may have.
I come to pop.
That's right.
It's on itunes.
The whole deal.
That was a really good comic too.
He's a very funny guy.
He just has a special that just came out
on epix.
Yeah.
It's probably come out already yet,
right?
Didn't it come out like last weekend or
something?
It's recent and it's like,
it's.
It's got to be.
What third,
fourth,
fifth of his nephew.
Do you ever talk to him about sourdough
bread?
Sourdough bread?
No.
Get lost for hours.
Really?
He's a sourdough wizard.
He knows all about.
He can make you sourdough bread.
He'll judge your bread.
You can make them some bread as,
hmm.
Good try.
But really what's wrong?
Yeah.
I feel like I love that quality.
I feel like there's so much that in
comics,
it's one of my favorite attributes about
comedians.
Are you like that?
This guy is a fucking hockey fanatic.
He
will punch you in the face if you say
anything.
You know what I mean?
Like they have their little fanaticism.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
that's,
that's his bread.
Any better than that?
My God.
What am I in France?
Am I in a bakery?
No,
I'm just baking bread.
It's awesome.
So cool.
That looks really good.
That bread looks fucking sensational.
Do.
There was one time I learned,
I went to a French cooking class,
a few,
like six slash seven years ago and I
learned a very basic,
but you know,
a little more sophisticated way to make
chocolate souffle,
you know,
like the hot lava where you crack and
there's a certain way you have to learn
the temperature of your oven.
Like the real way it works is to make
multiples because it might say $300,
but it cooks it in 17 minutes.
But at my house,
300 cooks it in 22 minutes.
Right.
So you,
because because they're actually,
different ovens will actually are
performing at a different level.
That is not necessarily what it says.
And you know,
you would learn how to mix and seasoned
the Ram Ramekins what's the range you
can error in?
Well,
the thing is,
I think most people would agree that you
want the souffle to have a crack.
You almost want it to be a crumble.
Like it breaks through the top.
Yeah.
But the middle stays a,
a sort of three quarters type of ooze
softness,
you know,
so you don't want it to bake fully
because then you have a cake basically.
Right.
So,
and if you go under the,
it could be like,
to,
you went like that.
That kind of down the middle.
Oh,
I see what you're doing.
Do know,
you know Bert crushers,
gonna hear this podcast.
Who's going to hear this souffle talk
and he's going to go off like a rocket.
No,
I know what you're doing.
Not at all.
I can't believe you would use my
podcasts like that.
I would never do something.
That's what he just did.
He had never done this before.
You've never had the center.
I want to fucking chocolate souffle now.
It's incredible.
Do you want vanilla ice cream with
yours?
Absolutely.
Have to.
And you have to let your.
Let your server note.
These things take 20 minutes or more.
Yeah.
They always tell you if a fancy schmancy
place.
Yeah.
Like if you go to a heads up if you want
the chocolate souffle.
Yeah.
Let us know now do.
When I learned that recipe I made about
30 in two weeks and uh,
yeah,
I think I put on about 30 pounds weeks.
So yeah,
definitely.
Do you now when you try to lose weight
for this competition?
Yeah.
Do you now look at this like this is the
new Thompson girl,
I'm just gonna eat healthy and lose all
this weight or do you go,
I'm just going to beat Bert Kreischer
then I'm going to go off like a rocket.
No,
I feel it becomes a little bit addictive
too.
When you start seeing some results.
Kinda reminds me of like saving money.
You're addicted to success.
When you save money and you see the
number go up,
you know like,
and I'm talking like even when you're
not making a lot of them,
you go like,
I'm going to save this amount of money.
Sometimes you'll surpass it and you'll
be like,
I don't even care about the
thing I thought I was saving money for.
It's fun to see it grow.
That becomes the addiction.
And he's like,
I just want to see it grow.
So though I think weight loss can be
like that.
You go like,
oh well just,
you know,
try and lose.
But then you see the number go down.
You're like,
oh,
I want to keep seeing,
keep going.
That's why when they have those
helicopter footage views of these
mansions in the hamptons and they're
pulling a guy out in handcuffs because
you stole $500,000,000
from his company,
that's what the fuck that's all about.
That's what that,
that simple human need to collect that
becomes,
you become some corporate villain that'd
becomes you fucking dig into the oil.
You know,
in the middle of the ocean and every CEO
in America.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a natural thing that people do.
Sure.
Was there weight loss ones healthy the
way last one is a healthy one,
but you bring up a really good point.
Yeah,
like people do get addicted to success
and they get addicted to A.
I think it's one of the most important
things about people is that you have to
find what little formula works for your
brain.
Everybody's brain is fucking different
to tell everybody.
They got to go for it and they got to
work out like the rock and they're going
to read a book a day like,
Hey,
hey,
slow the fuck down.
Everybody doesn't have to do that,
but you gotta find out what it is for
you,
and I think for almost everybody,
there should be something that you're
pursuing that you can get better at.
Meaning it could be art,
it could be like you're really in a
painting sculpture.
It could be a physical thing like maybe
a yoga thing or a martial arts thing or
fill in the blank with a hundred
archery,
a hundred different things that you
could chess that you could really get
into it.
Sure.
But I think when people work towards
something and then continue to do
something and try to improve and it
even.
It's just your recreational tennis game.
I think those things bring people
happiness because I think people have a
certain amount of built in desire to
overcome adversity,
overcome problems,
and we don't get enough of it in real
life.
Oh,
right.
Right.
So then you get something like a weight
loss challenge.
Yeah.
Anything like that where you have a
difficult struggle,
like you have an accomplishment to that
you're working towards.
It gives people that sense of meaning,
which ultimately that's the real
problem,
right?
With a lot of peoples that they don't,
they don't enjoy their life and so then
they start thinking about like,
what is the purpose of this?
Then because it just keep being
uncomfortable and not happy until you're
heart stops beating.
Yeah.
That's a miserable way to live.
It's a lot of people live like that.
That's why by the way,
is by my point for this too,
is that I think it's a great endorsement
of fat shaming because this is a healthy
result where you have two guys
ultimately.
Look,
it doesn't even matter.
We both.
We both fat,
shamed and insulted each other,
and then so did a lot of people.
Right.
Well,
you can get away with it because you're
a fat guy of Jamie started fat shaming
you.
We'd have a real issue.
I don't know,
man.
Jamie skinny.
He runs a lot,
but that's what I'm saying is that if we
benefited it low fat.
Yeah,
I know he's.
He's fine.
No,
no,
you did definitely,
but you guys are all both professional
comedians.
Like here's a perfect example.
What about a guy who's like a chef who's
just some fucking bomb ass chef and he's
a master chef and he keeps creating all
these new dishes,
but he's a fat fuck and he eats like a
pig and he drinks wine every night.
Like Gerard Depardieu.
Well,
look,
if that guy loves that,
you're right.
I'm not.
I'm not encouraging.
I'm not saying you should go with that
shame everybody I'm saying what I'm
saying is that there is an outcome in in
the in which it can be effective and not
negative.
I'm not saying,
hey,
anybody who's fat usually fucking fat.
I'm just saying that in this scenario,
in the outcome could be that like it
ends,
let's say it ended today and we are
where we are.
Both of us just actually ended up eating
healthier and working out for a month
and you know what I mean?
And we weigh less than we were healthier
than we were a month ago.
Well I think different people have
different abilities of tolerating jokes
pointed at them.
There a different aspect like,
well you could say something to me and
it probably has a different effect.
That's totally.
Maybe someone who doesn't do comedy or
maybe someone who's not used to someone
joking around with them.
I think that's,
that's a factor too.
I don't think you should emotionally
traumatized if that person.
I,
I hope I didn't sound like it was trying
to say that for some people it takes
being called fat to like get them off
their ass like some people.
My point is that I,
I,
I feel like I should say that with me it
worked and with some people.
Yeah.
I mean in a,
in a healthy way.
I never took it to like really,
I don't know,
it didn't affect me.
It affected me in a motivating way.
Well,
you and I have had a ton of
conversations over the years about a
health and fitness and weight loss and
stuff like that.
So if you wanted to do something,
I always felt like,
you know,
you would definitely do something and
you always worked out.
Yeah.
You know,
but yeah,
it just became,
you know,
it became something that I want to do
just channeled through this other thing.
That's ultimately what it was.
You know,
I've told this story before,
but when Kevin James was losing weight,
his manager at the time we got rid of
was telling him that if he loses weight,
he loses roles.
Yeah.
Who's telling them to not be healthy?
Because you won't.
You won't get as much work.
I had Amanda told me,
God damn crazy to the manager telling
me,
don't,
don't lose the weight.
Oh,
Jesus.
It's the same thing.
Like how that,
what the fuck kind of advice is that?
It's so crazy.
Don't,
don't be better as a person.
Just fuck up your comment.
They were thinking of casting.
They were like,
oh,
there's this many roles so you could get
one.
I wonder if they would approach it
differently now because now like a
casting and it's always going to be good
to be on a set of chrome,
so he's going to be good to be in a
movie.
But if you're someone like you who has a
successful podcast and then does netflix
specials,
I'll take that over all those things all
day.
It's a good life.
It's the best life.
You're creating your own shit.
You're doing your own thing,
you're doing it when you want and you're
being very prolific.
You're having fun.
Um,
you've done two specials in what?
Two and a half years?
Yeah.
That's pretty fucking bad ass.
You did
one and then he did another one was like
a year and a half later,
somewhere in that range,
but a 16 and 18 months later.
A man that's fucking giant.
Yeah.
I'm working on another one.
Yeah,
but see no interference man.
I know you don't have some crazy
executives that want to change the
direction of the show.
That's a whole world that I've learned.
It's really weird.
Like just from writing.
Yeah,
like having good script deals.
Yeah.
A lot of people get involved at first
they don't first there's nothing.
It's just like you and an idea and they
have conversations with that.
You just want to go,
why didn't you just say I had one one
time where we had this conversation with
an executive who said like,
we kinda want shows like,
and I'll just make it up,
right?
Like let's say like an HBO show,
it's not what this.
And you go like,
okay.
And that was just one of the things they
said.
And then on the first notes path,
which is like they read your first
draft.
The first thing that the same executive
said was just kind of feels like an hbo
show.
I don't really want it.
We were like,
what?
That's what you said.
And they're like,
no,
it's too much like that.
Oh my God,
I guess.
So that kind of,
that's the kind of shit you can deal
with on a,
on a writing deal.
You're like,
I don't know where to go from that.
The will.
Those deals are so odd.
Um,
you've worked with writers and sometimes
you know,
like you don't know a person,
you sit down with them,
start trying to write a script with them
and just gets really strange.
Yeah.
But when the,
when the execs come in is when it really
gets straightened out.
They have their own wacky ideas.
I pitched a show once and the guy was
pitching it without a panic attack.
He had a panic attack.
Think the pitch meeting where he held it
together,
but he had kind of a history.
He's a really nice guy,
very smart guy too.
He's real good writer.
Very funny guy.
Used to be comic and then the middle of
this meeting he just locked up,
see it,
you know,
just have really struggled to try to get
through the pitch in.
I couldn't jump in.
I mean if I jumped I didn't know what to
do.
Pitches are so funny.
Man.
Pitches are like for people that
haven't,
who haven't done it or don't like
pitching a show in my,
in my estimation and in my experience is
a lot like a blind date first,
like the first five minutes because
that's how like a pitch fields because
they'll be like,
hey you're,
I'm supposed to meet you too,
right?
And you're like,
yeah,
2:00.
And then they're like,
what's going on?
And then the,
the,
the usually the popular thing,
especially for comedy,
is there like first just be yourself and
just make it funny and you make a
decision.
Like you're like,
I'm a joke about this and you like
sometimes you get on a roll,
like people aren't jelling like this is,
it's funny natural conversation,
but sometimes it's like an awkward first
date where you're like yeah,
you like Moose and the person's like,
what?
And then you kind of feel it being
awkward and they start to be like,
I don't know if this is a great date,
you know?
And then they're like,
at that point,
like I don't know if I would go on a
second date with you.
It was like the field they go,
so what's the idea?
And you're already feeling like shit,
this isn't a good citizen,
a good date to begin with.
And then you start trying to throw out
an idea like well you'll like this even
though I don't think you like me,
you know?
And then you kind of either like either
rolls down that hill where you're like,
you leave the room.
Like that was awkward.
Right.
Which is still one step removed from an
audition though.
Additions the worst that is.
Yeah,
that is,
that is definitely the worst.
They also,
you feel like sometimes you walk in the
room in an audition and you feel like
the casting director or person made the
decision,
all right.
As you walk in the room you ever had
that where like you walk in and you're
like,
this person is definitely a no,
you have to keep going.
You gotta keep going.
I had to go check emails once during an
audition.
I was like,
uh.
Then another time I improvise a line and
the guy laughed and he goes,
that was rude,
and I was like,
what was.
He goes,
stick to the script.
I'm like,
Oh man,
punch to the fucking gut like that.
So
have you had a bad pitch?
Yes.
Well that was a bad pitch where the guy
had a panic attack.
That was the end of that.
I tried to pitch that like where you're
like,
and you're like,
this is going
terrible right now.
I pitched the show to do,
laughed make.
He thought it was joking when I was
totally serious.
It was about a bunch of girls who work
at a bikini pizza place during the day
and at night they fight crime and it's
called pizza slots.
Yeah.
They work at a place called pizza.
He's like,
all right,
what's the deal?
Bitch?
I wanted to do.
I was just a.
It was a stone idea I had,
but the idea was to do like like a super
over the top ridiculous,
like Charlie's angels type thing.
What's some girls that worked at a pizza
place?
Yeah.
That was the cover for this,
like secret crime fighting organization.
It was so stupid,
like I didn't have ideas for scripts and
have anything.
Let's see.
I,
I think I would at least be smiling if
that was the pitch.
He laughed.
He was like,
do that shit.
You received my mayor sizzle.
You saw that where I play.
I'm basically like a Rob Ford type
character.
Oh yeah.
I did see that play that we shot.
We shot that,
you know,
a couple of years ago and we pitched it
to a lot like we sent them that or we
bring it with us.
Right.
There's some people that laugh and like,
it's like I said,
it's like meeting a new person and there
was one guy who were like,
so um,
did you see the sizzle?
And he goes,
yeah.
He's like,
what else is there?
Like that kind of where he was just
like,
shuts it down.
Oh yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Let me hear this.
Harry Pryor.
Mr Mayor.
This is Stan Ramsey from the budget
office.
We're using stand for some healthcare
PSA.
He was recently diagnosed with cancer.
God,
I'm sorry,
Stan,
what kind long?
I don't even smoke.
One of the doctors say they gave me six
months,
you know something?
My aunt had lung cancer and they gave
her that same prognosis and that
was 14 years ago.
Really?
She remain cancer free.
Oh,
she died 13 and a half years ago.
Why?
Why are you telling me this?
Because it was like six months to the
day.
I mean,
these doctors,
they know their shit.
It's great meeting you,
Stan.
Hey.
And definitely swing by before
April.
We can set that up through my office.
What we decided to do,
like a Rob Ford character.
Yeah,
I mean like it wasn't pitch that way,
but as you know,
you can tell that was obviously the
influence.
Would you like to ramp it up and start
with Coke Dude,
like Rob Ford?
The thing that was so interesting about
him was they had video of him smoking
crack that this,
this leads down.
Oh,
he keeps going.
Black Dick for crack.
Oh Jesus.
Talking about black tech accused of it
and he's like,
oh,
second.
I don't think so.
But it was um,
you know,
it was a written by Tom Rubric.
It was a really funny.
He was a letterman writer for years and
years and years.
Really funny guy and I just played the
role,
but pitching that was like a,
was a rollercoaster because we had so
many good people like involved in it,
you know?
And I was like,
oh,
and then when you.
And then the pitch,
I just can't help it.
I know I'm repeating it,
but it's like a blind date.
It was like people would be like,
oh my God,
that's fucking awesome.
And then they'd be like,
I hate you.
Think in the position you're going to an
executive and you're saying,
hey,
spend money,
spend money.
I want to make a hit.
Yeah,
well what's your idea?
And then you know,
a bunch of girls in their bikinis and
they get the fuck out.
Get out of here.
Yeah,
that's stupid.
Stupid idea.
I'm glad they said no,
but every now and then someone will come
in their office and something clicks and
they decide,
oh,
let's take a chance and take a chance on
10 things and only one of them works.
I mean,
how many shoulders get fucking cancel
and it costs a shit load of money to
make happens all the time through.
Do you remember that show with the dude
from er?
What's his name?
John Noah.
Noah Wiley.
Memory.
He had a show like an alien show.
It was just crazy.
Special effects.
Alien invasion show and the hype the
shit out of it and spend all this money
on it.
If you're on a hit show,
you get so many more chances after that.
Oh yeah,
you keep putting you in.
Shit,
man.
There it is.
Falling skies.
It's kind of funny looking.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean like the.
The creatures were bad ass looking.
They're bizarre,
but as a weird show,
it's like,
what is going?
What is this?
Yeah,
like these creatures.
Is there a hanging out?
Like once you're hanging out with
aliens,
God damn,
that's hard to pull off.
You can turn your back to a lizard
person like you're not freaking out by
the fact that.
Thanks for another Goddamn planet behind
you.
You could look to the skies.
I would never let one of those fuckers
behind me.
Everywhere I'd walk,
I'd have my back to the wall.
Well,
it's every instinct had to be the kill.
Of course.
Dude.
You see that picture or the animated Gif
file that I put up on my instagram.
Which one of the owl
swooping in and Jack and this other
bird.
No,
I think it's a hawk at Jack's too or
some.
It looks like someone I did watch.
It was your tree cutting thing.
Holy Shit.
Is that district fuck?
Is that thing?
See that machine?
Yeah.
I've seen those before,
but that one seemed blood just picks up
efficiently or just cuts them in half
strips.
The look of that saws in half,
lifts it up in the air,
buzzes through all the bark as it's
holding it.
Again,
buzzes through the bark.
Totally strips the bark off.
I mean that's crazy.
Trips all the branches off.
Cuts it.
It's incredible lamp.
It's not dune manning that.
It's nuts.
Fucking wild.
Yeah.
It's so disturbing when you see the
brutal,
brutal efficiency of it.
Look how it just saw us through it and
all those wheels and gears on it.
Really incredible,
man.
Unreal.
Yeah,
but anyway,
that's not shit.
Compared to the owl.
The owl swoops down and jacks this bird.
I don't know what kind of.
But actually looks like a pigeon more
than it was like a hawk.
Right?
What does that look like?
That birds will be the eyes and the
distance.
The see the eyes.
Yeah.
Watch this mother fucker.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Other bird doesn't even know what
happened.
I was like,
Hey,
so you look at his face.
That looks like a raptor,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
I mean,
it has a beak on it though,
right?
I think that's some kind of a raptor and
a distance that's to mood and it sees
them and they don't see ya later and
they don't just grab you.
They kick you.
I guess it closes in.
Watch it one more time when we're like
say this now.
Those eyes look,
he's just fucking swooping in with those
eyes are so creepy.
Awesome.
To watch animals do it,
but watch how he kicks him.
Pitch like it's not just a grab,
it's a stun like it kicks them and then
sinks the clause at man and they.
Have you ever seen an towns the other.
They're incredible.
They're enormous.
That other bird turned its head was like
you say something like that.
Why is it that we take these ruthless
fascinating birds of prey,
these predators in nature and we make
them out to be these like lovely
sweetheart.
Like ours.
There's nothing funnier than Matt
Bronner's bit about als is a bit about
that.
That is hilarious.
So fucking ruthless.
Owls are how savage they are,
and then he hit me and I'm paraphrasing.
It's an older bit of his,
but it's when people are like,
oh,
they're still good.
I think it will rip your fucking face
off like it.
He has a really,
really well written bit about it.
But look at that.
Jesus.
People try to make them cute.
They're like,
oh,
they're adorable.
They're amazing.
Yeah.
They're night predators.
Night flying predators with giant eyes.
Eyes too,
man.
Yeah,
we were at,
um,
there's a rescue place that we go to.
Sometimes they,
uh,
they take care of wildlife and
rehabilitate them and they have this one
hour.
Well that was blind.
It pretty much blind.
It couldn't fly.
It would perch and it was a really small
owl.
And you sit there and look at this.
Then I think it's an s Omar.
I think the places,
I forget where it's at,
it's,
it's in the 808,
but it's got this little,
um,
this little owl and you're looking in
his fucking eyes,
man.
And you're like,
what a strange creature.
And his eyes look almost like cracked
because it was blind.
Like it looks like you're looking
through a crack television glass that's
bold.
Yeah.
He's old.
He's older.
Maybe something happened to his eyes to.
It might've been an injury or something
like that.
You know,
sometimes birds were flying to windows.
That has a lot.
We have,
um,
the outline of one on a window.
Oh,
Jesus.
Look at those eyes.
Is that,
that one bird blind out?
Yeah.
Like,
look at his eyes,
look like they're cracked inside.
And like there's something wrong.
Something missing.
Like he's looking at the universe.
That guy looks like a portal to the
heavens.
Look at his right eye.
It's like a constellation map or his
left eye.
It's true.
The left eye is a constellation of storm
thought.
Even a reflection of something that
looks like that.
That's what it looks like in that I.
well,
it's just such a bizarre animal.
Like if that didn't exist,
like if,
if there was no owls and then they just
found one,
you'd be obsessed.
You'd be like,
Holy Shit.
Have you seen that new animal?
They discovered?
Yeah.
It's called an owl.
They're calling in an owl dude.
It's this giant flying thing with huge
talents and it only hunts at night and
it's smart as fuck.
MMM.
They just swooped down and Jack
everything.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a.
that's an incredible predator.
Well,
it's really interesting that the balance
of those things other than when people
get infected or involved rather with a
balance of those things is like how many
of them exist.
It's all dependent upon how much there
is for them to eat.
Right.
That's like more rabbits.
There are.
The more rats there are,
the more the hours will thrive.
The mortal.
It's you.
If you didn't have those things,
like people are always in La.
They're always worried about coyotes.
Oh Man.
Fucking coyotes.
It's bullshit.
We got to get these coyotes out of our
neighborhood.
Oh,
do you like rats?
Yeah.
Do you like rats?
No.
No,
I don't like rats.
Rats.
Get to your fucking house.
Coyotes.
Yeah.
My Cat a.
don't put your cat outside.
Fucking mittens doesn't know what the.
What the Hell it God.
Damn Coyote is right.
Right
now.
It's there.
Yeah.
People flip out about that need.
Coyotes.
I seen a fucking coyote jogging down,
trotting down fountain with that dog and
its mouth before at night,
late,
late at night,
it's dark.
And then I saw a,
um,
a pack of them came to an apartment
building I lived at once.
And you heard weird squeaking,
like screeching.
At first I thought it was an animal was
hurt.
Where were you?
I was in Silverlake,
Holy Shit.
And I was like,
man,
what is that?
Sounds like a dog's crying.
And I opened the door and the door that
was near the street,
the apartment there had a glass door
open,
but a screen door and there was,
they had a bigger dog and then there was
like six coyotes trying to get that
dog and they were making this shreddable
crying noise.
Shit.
We will fucking fixated.
Like,
oh my God.
Like I first said it.
I thought they're going to fucking run
through that door manager if they got
through and just made a blood bath out
of the hallway.
He came down.
He found this coyotes now kill as a
pitch.
I'm already in on this one.
Okay.
I'm going to pitch this.
If I can.
Six coyotes.
See a dog break in and make a bloodbath
of an entire family.
Jesus.
Halloween,
2017 coyotes.
Wild coyotes.
Just start killing people.
Why not?
I don't like it.
It makes me uncomfortable.
All right,
then.
Don't fucking buy it.
I just tried to sell.
All right dude.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Let's go.
Okay.
We all have different tastes.
I'm not into that.
They knew it was into it.
Do you know the coyotes or wolves?
No.
Yeah,
they're wolves.
They're uh,
they used to call them prairie wolves.
That's why they can breed with bowls.
Like they,
uh,
they,
they have that thing called a Coi Wolf.
That's like a hybrid between a coyote
and a wolf.
The,
it's not just a hybrid between a coyote
and a wolf.
There's actually a lot of them.
Now there's like the percentage of
hybrid.
It's like sometimes a hybrid mixes with
a pure coyote.
Sometimes a hybrid.
Mix it with another hybrid,
sometimes a hybrid mixes with another
wolf.
So there's like a bunch of different
levels of coyotes and wolves.
But ultimately they're all wolves.
Coyotes are a type of wolf.
But the difference between dogs and
wolves as dramatic.
Right.
I think I read that lonely by image.
By image only.
Yeah.
The genetics are the exactly the same.
But then the,
the natural abilities of them that I
shouldn't say the genetics because
obviously they vary,
right?
Yeah.
But what I should say is when you
research a dog's DNA,
all dogs came from wolves.
Hmm.
So they became a dog.
But obviously an English bulldog is very
different than A.
Husky is very different than a
rottweiler is.
There's a lot of weird variations in
genes,
but all of them originated with wolves.
Interesting.
Yeah.
They didn't even know how.
They don't know what I mean.
What the coyotes come from.
Coyotes are.
Wolves are wolves up in.
Some coyotes have bread with dogs.
When we did a fear factor shoot,
once we stumbled upon this,
like I'm a litter of puppies that this
Labrador had had with the coyote.
It was really weird.
Do you ever see mountain lion?
I've seen mountain lions.
I've seen him twice.
Yeah.
I saw one in Colorado and I saw one in
Santa Barbara,
so I wanted Montecito,
Montecito neighborhood.
We were driving to a restaurant.
We're driving up the street and this
thing runs across the road and I'm
looking at it and was like,
Oh,
I saw its tail and then oh my God,
it's a cat.
That's a cat.
That's a big cat.
Holy Shit.
It's such a different feeling,
man.
When you see,
and when I say big cat,
it was probably about 60 or 70 pounds
anywhere between.
I'm just guessing anywhere between 50
and 70 pounds.
It wasn't big like a big mountain lion,
like some of them get to be 150 plus
pounds.
It wasn't like that big.
Can it be bad motherfuckers?
They're all bad motherfuckers.
I'm my point is that 51 will fuck you
up.
Of course.
$50.
Mountain Lion will fuck you up man.
You don't want to see that.
No,
that's a terrible.
So to see it in this really nice
neighborhood,
we went to this really nice Italian
restaurant.
We're driving down a residential street
and we're like,
Holy Shit,
that's a killer.
Just Roman looking for dogs and shit.
Yeah.
What if it's saw you walking your dog,
you know they'll take your dog.
A coyote is take your dog all the time.
You hear stories about old ladies and
Brentwood walking there.
Poodles,
Click,
click,
click to hear the clicks of the nails of
the coyote behind them and the kind of
just snatches that dollar right off the
leash.
Yeah,
that's horrible.
They'll eat anything.
Especially when they're in urban
environments,
they actually target cats and dogs
because cats and dogs kill a lot of what
they kill,
so they don't just look at a cat.
This is one of the things I found out
from this coyote America book that I
read was that they don't just look at a
cat as a something to eat.
They really look at it as a competing
predator.
Oh,
so I got to get rid of that.
Yeah,
because that things eating all the
fucking birds,
right?
Things.
Eating all the rats so things eat.
Know it's killing everything.
I ever thought of that.
Yeah,
they,
they don't like it.
They don't like having competing
predators around competition mean
they'll kill it.
If it was a chicken,
obviously they would kill it.
If it was something that wasn't a
competing like it was a bunny rabbit,
they would kill it too,
so it's hard to say why they're killing
it.
They easily could be killing it for
food,
but they believe that they target those
animals because those animals are fellow
predators.
Interesting.
They must know.
They must be able to tell when
something's a predator.
I,
I saw this piece of news piece about how
they would have much better chance of
survival.
The mountain lions out here if we had
overpasses over the freeways for them to
roam.
Yeah.
They're going to build those.
Are they going to build it in Europe?
They have someplace I've got to do.
I'm here and I'm gonna spend millions of
dollars and people were up in arms.
People fuck these things.
Well,
one of them I'm just killed.
I think it was like,
what do we will look this up the other
day,
right?
Twelve Alpacas or 1111 alpacas and one
goat in Malibu.
Just went on a rampage.
Just decided I just want to jump the
fence and fuck these things up.
Didn't eat one of them.
Killed them for the fuck of it.
I think it was like,
like for fun or because they saw it as a
good time.
Yeah.
Good time.
Can't resist.
There's a bunch of things stuck in a
cage.
I get in that cage.
I get over the top of that thing.
Alright,
I'm going to do it.
I mean it's like probably a thrill for
him.
Sure.
These are these totally team things that
aren't going to run good.
Like think about how many times I think
is trying to sneak up on a deer.
The deer season point.
Point.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I mean how many times did that thing.
I have to go on a stock before it
actually gets a deer walked out of that
cage.
Like it just,
it just satisfies.
This probably came from all over the
place.
Uh,
uh.
Yeah.
See if they did,
they gave a depredation order to kill
this thing and people are up in arms
about that.
They're like,
no,
we want the monster that kills the
Alpaca.
Stay near our children,
our house.
She.
Oh,
don't kill it.
I'm a big mountain lion fan.
Folks,
don't get me wrong.
I'm a big fan of wolves to.
But when you got something in your
neighborhood that kills 11 alpacas,
what if it was a werewolf?
Okay.
What if a Werewolf was in your
neighborhood and decide to kill a bunch
of sheep?
Got Reprieve.
They decided to change this.
Wow.
They gave a depredation order,
which means the rancher was allowed to
kill it.
So it looks like the mountain lion got a
reprieve.
The neighborhood offered to shoot the
big cat known as p 45.
Can make that a little bigger.
Thank you sir.
Uh,
for Victoria von Pearling.
But she told reporters it was never her
intention to have a,
have the cougar killed.
Instead,
she said she'd hook game officials would
capture it and get it away from her
ranch.
Okay.
So the woman who,
uh,
have the Alpacas,
didn't want the mountain lion to be
killed.
She indicated that public outrage
might've played a role in her decision
adding.
She was surprised by the vitriol.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
Well,
the people who don't know,
especially someone who's like a rancher,
is raising the Alpacas and they're not
paying attention to how nutty like
social justice warriors get online when
it comes to things like this.
But here's the thing folks,
you got a problem.
If you've got something that's in your
neighborhood that kills a lot of
livestock,
especially that the way it did it,
there were killed a bunch of them and
didn't even eat it.
Where would they drop that thing by the
way?
You think?
If they were trying to do that,
they would take it somewhere like big
bear or you know,
somewhere probably close by,
but far enough away that it would,
you know,
maybe could stake out a new territory,
but there's no guarantee that it doesn't
come back.
See,
the thing about mountain lions as
opposed to people is they know where the
fuck they are and they know how to get
home.
Like they have some weird built in sense
of direction.
Like mountain lions will travel hundreds
of miles in their lives,
hundreds,
hundreds of miles,
and they'll get back to where they were
due.
There was a mountain man that was killed
in fucking Connecticut and it originated
in South Dakota.
That's a really far.
Yeah.
It was killed by a car and Connecticut
and they were like,
what in the fuck is this?
Yeah.
Why is there a mountain lion on the
road?
See if you can find that story.
Jesus.
So I don't butcher with my shit.
Memory didn't take Algebra in today.
No,
no,
I forgot.
Forgot to grab it on the way out now.
I'm stupid.
Keep you sharper.
All for sure.
And the phlegm didn't help either.
Phlegm at the beginning of the podcast
time yet Connecticut Mountain Lion
walked from South Dakota.
$1,500,
140 pound male.
Cougar,
which is a big cat estimate between two
and five years old,
almost certainly left its native habitat
to look for mates but went in the wrong
direction according to Adrian.
Why little the animal?
How do you say that name?
Adrian?
Why Devon?
Devon Devon.
I'm a mammal ecologist with the
Wisconsin Department of natural
resources.
He was looking for love in all the wrong
places,
is one of those expressions.
He was struck by an Suv on the Wilbur
Cross Parkway in Milford,
Connecticut.
I know where that is.
I used to play pool around there.
Just play pool and Milford.
Yeah,
and that area.
It was Milford on June 11th.
The driver was unhurt,
but the cougar died at the scene.
Fuck did that.
Cooter was just glass and then the guy
hit him.
That's interesting that they initially
thought that had been released from
captivity given that no mountain line
had been cited in the state for more
than 100 years.
Jesus,
that's so long,
man.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
they can.
They've spotted them and a lot of places
and now they're fact like a big one is
Florida,
you know,
the cougars in Florida with a legend
just a few years ago and now there's a
lot of video of him.
Have you seen the one where the lady is
walking down a fence?
She's walking on a bridge rather,
and as she's walking down the bridge,
the fucking mountain lions on the bridge
and runs past and she filmed the whole
thing.
She's freaking out.
No,
hold on.
it's a big one too and it's just,
it's a little narrow ass.
Wouldn't bridge check this shit out.
Like wash.
Give us some volume.
Jamie.
Give me some fucking volume.
Watch this.
Where's the volume you're washes.
Watching my God.
Watch.
Do to do well.
Are you fucking kidding me?
This for the people listening,
not watching this mountain lion,
which is really big runs by this lady.
I guess it's a Florida Panther,
but it's the same animal,
right?
It runs by this lady within a couple of
feet over.
Oh yeah.
Maybe one right next to her and it's
huge.
This cat is goddamn enormous,
but it's,
you know,
she's lucky that she's standing.
Was that,
is it.
Does it say in her district?
In her description as your mom's house?
She wasn't my mom.
God.
Hey,
mom lives in Florida.
She does Naples,
Naples,
corkscrew,
swamp sanctuary.
They're eating rednecks out there folks.
Don't fucking kid yourself to not miss.
And Man,
he was out there.
Frog and he went out there.
Frog and we never heard from him again.
There's a lot you.
Oh yeah,
they,
everything eats you.
You go out there and like,
fucking what was that one?
Do you remember that one movie?
Goddammit.
Southern Comfort.
Do you remember of that Southern
Comfort?
No.
Southern Comfort is about some national
guard.
It's a fucking good movie.
Goddammit.
Before I say that,
it might not hold up.
Okay.
It might be one of those.
It'll.
Yes,
I know exactly what you mean when you
were 16.
Roadhouses shit.
Patrick.
Lazy.
No karate for real.
You fucking really asking me that
southern comfort.
Yeah.
So it was about these national guard
guys that went down into the swamp and
um,
they were doing some sort of like
exercise and they piss somebody off and
they got in some sort of an exchange
with people and they shot at someone who
they shot at someone with blanks.
They didn't have real bullets.
They were just being an asshole.
And when they shot at someone they shot
at like some,
some Cajun guy who like lived in the
swamps and they,
um,
they set up waiting for these guys
and they took one out with a rifle,
a from a distance.
And when he died,
they went,
oh my God,
like this guy is shot and killed in
front of them.
And then it became,
I don't want to give away spoiler alert,
but it becomes these guys trying to
survive in the woods with these crazy
fucking cage and people that have been
living there their whole lives.
Whoa,
dude.
It's deep.
It's sluts,
but it's fucking.
Let's go see pizza sluts.
You knew it was bullshit going in,
right?
That was the part,
the guiding get.
Yeah.
That's a good fucking movie,
man.
Yeah,
it's a good fucking movie.
I remember.
This might suck.
I'm going to warn you if you go watch
it.
Joe Rogan.
I saw altered states.
That movie's fucking terrible.
And you're right.
Yeah,
you're right.
Altered states changed my life,
but it's terrible.
Yeah,
it was a lot of old movies.
Don't hold up.
Nope.
Try watching that shit today.
Comedies too.
Sometimes you,
I guess the funniest shit.
And then you watch it again.
You're like,
someone was telling me that about
stripes.
They tried to watch stripes.
Yeah.
And like this is fucking terrible.
If you see,
I mean,
you know,
the,
the thing that you don't give enough
credit to on something like that,
something like stripes was one of the
blueprints for how to make that kind of
comedy and if you're somebody that
didn't see stripes but so 100 bad
versions of stripes and then you see it,
then it looks bad because you've,
you know,
formulaically who the characters is this
character,
that character.
You've seen versions of all the jokes,
you know it.
So then it feels like,
oh,
this is just another bad when it's
actually the original.
Right.
It's also a problem that like everything
else,
it just kinda gets,
keeps getting better.
People get better.
Yeah.
Like superbad.
Like superbad didn't exist before.
Stripes.
Right.
You know,
unlike stripes kind of opened the door
for movies like Superbad,
but ultimately superbad funnier.
Yeah.
It's better.
It's bad movie.
Damn,
that movie's funny.
He's really funny.
That's a funny.
That's a fucking by yourself holding
your sides at home.
Laughing your ass off.
Funny moving.
Yeah.
You're right.
So the ones that they really knock it
out of the park today,
but it has to be one that they knock.
There's a lot of shit,
but there's always a lot of shit
comedies.
There was shit comedies then the shit
comments.
So really good comedy lately.
Have you seen one that Fred eichler
glass and video fucking glass and
Jamie's seen a good movie.
Good comedy.
I'm trying to remember one that I've
seen recently that was really funny.
I heard trainwreck was funny,
but I didn't see it.
Mm.
I would name one,
one movie.
I'm trying to think.
God dammit.
What about a good moment?
Have you seen a good movie or recently?
Um,
I saw shark bites the shallows.
I saw that.
What's that?
That.
I mean it was just a entertaining.
It was a blake lively alone sharks after
her,
you know,
it was silly.
It wasn't like for what
it was,
it was like entertaining.
You know,
it's problem with movies is now hbo and
Netflix because they're so fucking
digest clanged it over the head.
Like when you watch a new episode of
game of thrones,
you're so goddamn invested in that show.
Well,
they can go so much further with where
the story's going to go.
Dan goes so deep,
you know,
if you know you have 10,
13,
15 hours to tell a story,
you can really make those hours
meaningful.
It's totally different than like a great
show that you get into.
I mean it just changed like due to the
fucking.
I think I've told you if you watched
Fargo the TV series or.
It's amazing.
It's fucking unbelievable.
There's too many good shows.
That guy is unreal.
Noah,
I forget his last.
That guy is unreal,
man.
Those shows are so good.
Is Billy Bob Thornton still in it?
It would know.
He's the most.
Don't tell me anything.
The can stop saying,
don't you spoil or the.
No,
I won't.
I won't spoil anything,
but you should watch season one and
threaten me though.
Dude.
What?
Deadpool was pretty good.
I was like,
I don't know if you consider necessarily
I would call that a superhero comedy and
I agree with you.
That was really funny that,
that was a good movie.
That was really fucking funny.
And um,
that dude's really funny.
Ryan O'neal,
he's fun.
Reynolds Reynolds,
same guy.
Same Guy.
Handsome guys around for a thousand.
Alex,
his wife is the star of the,
of the shark one.
I saw that.
His wife.
Well,
there you go.
There you go.
Makes Sense.
Why it was great.
Yeah,
he's a funny dude.
That was a good movie.
Really funny.
Uh,
I wonder if that new one,
that new one has like a pretty funny
trailer.
The Anniston work one.
You know what I mean?
Christmas party.
It's like,
it's,
it's like an r rated comedy.
It looks like it could be fun.
I haven't seen it.
Jennifer Aniston's.
I would just said it's going to be
funny.
I think so you just said that.
Yeah.
It's got Tj Miller.
It's got some money.
Okay.
That's what I like.
Good Solid Jennifer Aniston movie.
Dude,
if you're not a fucking friends.
So I'd never watched friends.
Now it's,
it's very,
it's just formulaic.
Man is generic,
but it people like the fencers.
Yeah,
I think so.
Sure.
It just hit,
it,
hits all the notes.
If you're writing a sitcom,
each of those characters plays one of
the like archetype people and they just
got people that had chemistry.
I fucked up.
I never watched Seinfeld when I was on
the air and I never watched friends.
Seinfeld.
I've watched a couple of frasiers and I
would always watch it for like 10
minutes and go,
what the fuck am I doing?
Seinfeld is really the only,
I think one that's.
If you're a comic,
do you ever watch mad about you and go,
is there something with the.
Am I thinking wrong?
Well,
I would see people watch it like family
members and laughing and that's when I,
that's when I would think something's
wrong with me.
And then after I was like,
you're retarded.
You know,
she was.
She said to him,
what do you think that is?
You're not retarded,
but I think the people that are so
laughing.
Do you think it's an intelligence thing?
Yes.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
They're tapped to.
They're tapping into dl sperm there,
figuring out the people that focus
better pro because you went different
shows.
Come on Bro.
You know what I saw?
That's fucking excellent.
All bullshit aside.
I don't care what you like.
But uh,
um,
black mirror or dark mirror,
black hair and black mirror,
black mirror.
I watched the one where the guy,
I finally watched it and I went right to
the one where the guy records memories.
You.
Everyone can.
Holy Shit.
Have you seen what we've been talking
about for so long that,
that show's phenomenal?
Have you seen the.
You're trying to one up me motherfucker
masturbation one.
No,
no.
I'm saying on that show on Black Mirror.
What do you mean the,
the,
the.
There's an episode on masturbation.
I've only seen two episodes.
I saw the first one where the guy fucks
the pig and I saw this.
This is the second one that I saw was,
okay,
I went to watch this one specifically
because it's about a subject that we're
constantly talking about,
which is,
which is recording memories that they're
going to be able to record memories.
It's 100 percent.
It's gonna happen,
it's just a matter of whether or not we
can survive the next hundred years or
whatever it is before we get hit by an
asteroid or.
But one of these days they're gonna.
Just think about how crazy it is that
200 years ago,
if you wanted a painting is something if
you wanted to picture something,
rather you would have to paint it.
You'd have to draw or paint it.
And that was so,
so recent.
It was 200 years ago.
Not Long.
Yeah.
No photographs ever.
So no one had ever seen anything that
they didn't see.
You either saw it or you didn't say it.
Sure.
So what we have done is let you see
things you've never gotten anywhere
near.
Like in some weird way.
We've already connected people's
memories.
Like my memories of you know,
anything.
Whatever I did this last weekend,
I could show it to you on my phone.
Hey,
we went fishing in Hawaii.
Look at some of my memories.
I'm showing you my fucking memories and
just shitty.
They're like Morse code,
you know,
they're like a,
a fucking teletype machine there.
Facts,
they're not the internet and I think
it's crazy that your children will be
able to grow up and think about how
about yours as well?
I'm saying in my children,
because he might fucking kids.
Dude.
So my kids will go to you.
Show me a Sicilian section.
You piece of shit.
The snapchat spectacles,
which is the early version of what
you're talking about to do a surgery
like,
oh,
what kind of surgery is this?
Oh my God,
Dude.
Warning.
I want a heads up.
I gotTa pee,
man.
Go pee bro.
I watched this guy get cut open.
But that's super interesting.
Yes,
it's through his eyes.
Right?
So the snapchat glasses or essential,
uh,
cameras that are connected to the
Internet.
Yeah.
To your snapchat account,
I would assume.
But uh,
yeah,
that's nuts.
Hands off camera.
So you don't have to.
People love them.
People were having sex on it and like
how dare they,
I don't know if they're sharing the porn
videos online but,
but they can watch each other fuck
through that.
So it's essentially the same thing.
They've already got it.
God Damn,
I knew it.
Not like it's anything brilliant on that
Black Mirror episode.
The different concepts that come up with
that are super interesting,
outstanding job and it was also weird
how their eyes would glaze over when
they would look at their own so they
could at their stuff,
through their eyes.
I'm giving it away too much.
Right?
It's been out for quite a while,
so what I didn't see it don't spoil
alert things.
People are mad at me for spoiler alert
in the marketing dead.
What are you going to do folks?
I said,
spoiler alert,
just hit that button quick.
If you're nowhere near it and you hear,
spoiler alert,
you're not near your falling.
You're like fuck.
By the time you get there we should give
them like spoiler alert and then 10
seconds like next time we're going to
say something about something.
We'll say spoiler alert and then
countdown.
That'd be annoying though,
right?
For sure.
You know what will I should have like a
countdown on my desk,
like a little thing that I could press
at any moment and it just gives me a
flat 10 seconds.
Can that be done?
And then I'll just keep talking and I'll
give you a spoiler alert.
Then they hit the button one.
I'm about to tell you.
I definitely get out of the fucking
room.
If you want to know,
I'll let you know.
You got seven seconds.
Five,
four.
Then how are you gonna?
Talk about it for 10 minutes.
Well,
tough shit more.
But um,
what I thought was really interesting in
the Black Mirror thing is that when they
had that one late can't talk about that
I'll spoil or it um,
but I just thought the way they handled
it was really,
really well done because it,
it,
it seemed like normal people have today
that we're faced with this technology.
Was it as opposed to like.
Westworld is weird to me.
I love westworld.
I'm a huge fan of it,
but it's weird to me that it's 30 years
in the future,
but everything is pretty standard.
Like the way they're doing everything
with a tablet and the everything,
the way they're walking around their
apartments,
it all looks kind of the same.
Whereas if you go to 1970 and you look
at 1970 as opposed to the year 2000,
there's a giant difference in that 30
years.
I would think that whatever the fuck,
I mean if they're that close to they,
they made these goddamn robots and then
30 years later they're the.
They're still fairly similar like get
the fuck Outta here.
Like 30 years later you have.
You still,
you guys are still using ipads.
Like really?
Is that what's going on?
Like you haven't transcended into new
dimensions.
We're not walking through artificial
black holes that you make with your
blender now.
I mean 30 years from now someone could
create some mind numbing world changing
shit.
It's not just going to be a robot.
You can fuck or shoot,
you know it's going to probably be over.
That's the only like suspension of
disbelief thing that fucks with me is
that they've been doing that park for 30
years after watching it and having
theories on it.
That could be like maybe that's all
they've shown us so far is that might
not be the actual you here.
My theory is that how come when a
spoiler alert,
if you cut them open,
you see the robot parts,
one of them,
but when you're building them now know
when one's were murdered,
when he murked all those people and
chopped them all up.
Remember that there was a scene that you
see like robot parts sticking out of
people.
They were all laying down the whole
ceiling.
Remembers seeing the inside of the
worse.
The chick,
I forget who.
Anyway,
there was.
Yeah,
there's that.
But when you watch them construct the
things,
you don't see any of that stuff.
You see synthetic bone or something like
that.
So what the fuck is going on Jamie?
That's what I'm saying.
If you see that,
that last scene where they show the
girl's arm ripped off.
I know.
Did you hear that?
They're not going to read band dominus.
They're not gonna do season two until
2018 as well.
I mean they,
they have announced that they're going
to do it and I probably have to.
It's 2017 now.
Basically they have to fill that by
2018.
You think Bert would still be fat?
One hundred percent?
Absolutely.
You really committed to this.
Of course,
man,
he's a guy with feelings.
I know and I love him.
He's one of my best friends.
Would do anything for that guy if you
can get inside his head and change him.
Yeah.
What'd you stop getting them?
Stop Drinking?
No.
What about after January third?
Definitely not.
No.
I want them to be happy.
The only way he'll be happy if he keeps
drinking.
Absolutely.
Maybe with new technology,
they'll figure out a way to fix your
liver.
Maybe they'll will have like a stem cell
liver cleanse and they'll just pump that
shit in there.
I'm way,
way into the burden.
Then future,
maybe I'll do something like that and
maybe burt will have to drink more
because it's liver will be so good that
the booze won't last.
Right.
So we're up in like 20 minutes.
Fucking partying harder.
He's a fun guy to party with.
Oh yes.
Have you ever seen him do stand out with
a shirt on?
Yes.
Back in the times I saw him for a while
doing it.
He used.
He used to do it.
He only started doing that,
I feel like about two years ago,
maybe three.
I feel like it's fairly recent in the
time that I've known him and seeing him
just stand up and um,
and I think it was since then.
Have you ever seen him do standup with a
shirt on?
No,
I haven't either.
Yeah,
it's,
um,
but it works.
It's almost like part of the persona,
you know.
Well,
it's like,
I forget when he did news to dude.
Was he bigger than you or is it just me?
No,
man.
we're about the same.
About the same size.
How does his pants stay right above his
dick like that?
That seems impossible.
It seems like belt is about right there.
Yeah.
But that's different.
Photo Moshe Kasher showing US goods
tidy.
Whities Moshe is a funny guy too,
man.
He's got a new show coming out on comedy
central.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
it's a really cool idea.
I'm sure it will be back to talk to very
smart dude.
Yeah.
Very,
very smart.
Is that Bryan county showing his abs
with Bert Kreischer?
That right below that I would say to
you,
I'm so sorry Brian,
but when that's a little tiny image,
it does look like Brian can tell me.
It doesn't say I'm looking at Eddie.
Do you shred it?
Dah,
Dah.
So it was.
Burt looks good there.
No,
that's not true at all.
Um,
Eddie is a crossfit shit.
Oh,
is he loves cross versus got that
bloated distended thing though.
It's booze.
That's what I'm saying.
That's it.
There's no way I can get out of that.
I think he could once he down to now,
was he claiming?
I don't know because he hasn't claimed
in a minute.
Oh well here's a photo that he keeps
bringing it up.
Have him back when he was real thin when
he was real young,
like in college.
That's hilarious.
He's bringing that one out.
But getting back to that bro.
And he did a,
he did his promo for last week where he
used a 10 to 15 year old picture,
but he just put it like with the date
and the end,
he was so much thinner in it.
It was ridiculous.
He did.
But he was just like,
I'll be here this week.
It's hilarious.
That's really funny.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's not fun when you want your body to
get big and fat and you can't turn it
around.
Yeah.
I mean,
you can.
Not Everybody.
I'm saying that like we're in a position
to do it.
That's why I think this is a good thing.
Well,
everybody can't.
I look.
Wow.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
That's like 2000.
It's weird that you decided to use that
picture.
Maybe he's trying to fuck with you.
He was.
Oh,
absolutely let you know.
He did.
I didn't tell you what he did.
This is so fucking funny.
So this is it.
This is what I was going to tell you.
Congrats on the new house.
The Rock Burger really get a package
from the rock.
Burnt.
Burt sent me a bicycler set.
Burns Chrysler sent me a box of cookies
and that,
that was the card because he's tagged
the rock on a few things in the rock.
Has retweeted it and mentioned him and
he told me about it.
So then he sent me a box of cookies to
the house.
And it said congrats on the new house,
the rock.
So that was,
that was trying to fuck with me having
me eat cookies and that it's coming.
It's coming from the Rock John.
So I gave them away immediately.
Good for you,
man.
Good for you.
Yeah,
we're in a battle dude.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I eat sugar free pudding.
I don't know.
No,
I ever.
Every time I eat them,
I'm just going to fucking trick my body
with the sugar free pudding.
It's got high protein,
high protein sugar.
If you're putting either something that
it does to your ass.
Oh really?
There's something that happens.
It's kind of mixes up with real food.
Yeah.
It's a gang fight,
which we fucking sugar fruit.
Maybe I'm eating the wrong card.
I don't know.
Maybe there's a good one.
Dumps left her less horrific in the last
30 days for sure.
Sure.
Yeah.
Well,
the more salad you eat,
the more it's going to be real smooth.
Yeah.
That's a big one with people.
People that just eat meat,
man.
You doing your body a disservice.
You got to eat a lot of vegetables.
So important people don't want to do it
because God dammit,
if you've got a cheeseburger with blue
cheese on it,
you see the blood just kinda like
dripping onto the bond.
Put some Jalapenos on that budget.
Fit maybe some age,
some thick fucking dark red is some
juicy iceberg lettuce and you want to
get busy with that cheeseburger for
sure.
That's my favorite,
I think.
I think you should need to half one to
take it from me.
The guy who eats three meals to see to
have a cheeseburger.
Just put it away.
Yeah,
eat a salad.
Sounds good.
I like salad.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going on it man.
Do you ever do Kale shakes?
No.
Time to step it up.
Step it up the Kale shake.
Step up your game.
Let's make a video video.
I'll bring the ingredients over to your
house and I'll bring you a blendtec
blender as a house warming gift.
Shit,
you need one of these days.
We're going to do.
I'm going to show you how to make them
too.
They taste good and then I'm gonna.
Show you how I do it.
It just tastes like shit.
Brutal.
They're brutal,
but I
swear to God you'll,
you'll drink this and you'll.
You'll want to run up the side of a
fucking mountain and punch a mountain
lion right in the day.
You eat this every morning.
No,
no,
no.
I don't think it's smart to eat a lot of
the same things all the time.
I think it's good to mix it up a little
bit,
but when I do do it as I feel it,
I mean I always drink like you saw him
when I came in here.
I was eating a big salad.
Always eat salads,
a lot of vegetables,
but the amount of nutrition that you get
the Kale shake,
like think about like,
this is what I take.
This is my recipe.
I take four big stocks of Kale for.
Yeah,
for chop that shit up top,
top,
top.
Then I'd take a cucumber chop that bench
top,
top.
Trump,
trump,
trump.
Then I take a giant chunk of ginger,
giant,
like almost like a pager,
like a half a pager,
like a half a pagers.
Good.
Throw that bitch in there,
four cloves of garlic,
get it for four cloves and I used to go
with a full pair,
but then I go with a half a pair now.
Now I go half a pair.
You'll get that immediately led should.
It should be part of the font.
Then on top of that for stalks of celery
or two,
excuse me,
two stalks of celery and then mct oil.
Mct Oil is important because in order
for you to buy your body to accurately
process,
like to get the most like more
efficiently process vitamins you want
want them to be attached to fats and a
lot of cases,
a lot of different vitamins or flight.
Your body absorbs better with fat and
mct oil is a healthy fat and it's.
It's good for brain function.
A lot of other things.
That's where it gets tricky.
You can't put too much because if you
put too much in here,
asshole,
well really just protests.
Protests.
It goes on a riot.
You go on an asshole riot like I've had
some asshole riots were you,
you?
You're walking towards the bathroom and
all the sudden out of nowhere,
like you have to take a shit and you go
like,
oh well I'll go in the bathroom and
you're like,
oh my God,
I'm not going to make it.
Like you see the bathroom.
Be like,
Whoa,
whoa.
I don't know what the number is.
But to me caution,
err on the side of caution with uh,
with the mct oil,
maybe just a couple of tablespoons full
of fish oil,
you know,
like there's this restaurant that used
to go to on the east side,
Don Felix Peruvian place and they would
make this dish called Palo,
which is so hard for that.
Sounds like you should be on Narcos,
man.
It's a heart.
It's a fucking traditional Peruvian
dish.
Which meat?
Potato,
like chopped up fries.
Basically tomatoes,
Rice.
But they would oil like make it on a pan
with lots of oil.
I used to be able to fart song,
like with total control,
you know,
it could be like bro,
bro,
Bro.
Because of so much oil in my system,
it's probably really good for you.
Yeah.
Fuck you gotta.
Try this man.
I'll take it to this place if you want
to go.
Did you see that article that was
released that showed that the sugar
companies in the 19 fifties were bing
scientists to report?
Yes.
It was saturated fat that was causing
people to get sick and have heart
attacks.
Don't flesh.
That was the fifties or sixties and
they've been.
We've been saying that ever since,
so 50 years ago,
someone lied.
Look at that in that.
It's crazy because all these years
people have like automatically connected
saturated fat and heart disease,
saturated fat and all these problems,
but there's,
there's like a need that your body has
for saturated fat.
A lot of these scientists that did this,
they just fucking lied.
They were paid off by the sugar industry
to make it seem like saturated fat was
what's fucking people up.
However,
someone just sent me.
I'm Dr Rhonda.
Patrick actually just sent me something,
an article that,
um,
there's a new study that came out that
shows that the real problem they think
now with saturated fats is when
saturated fats are mixed with processed
foods,
processed foods.
And saturated fats together as a
combination like pos,
processed sugars,
and things along those lines,
and mixed with saturated fats can be
very bad for you.
Right?
So it's just you can go on the fat kick
but don't mix it with that sugar.
Right.
But even when we were talking about this
before the podcast or we're.
We're talking about beginning of the
podcast,
the protein thing was before,
before it was you,
you saw.
It's all moderation is all balanced.
Like you can't have too much protein.
If you eat too much protein,
your body starts to convert it to sugar.
Dude,
that's what I was doing with meat all
the time.
Yeah,
I think way too big a portions and then
you see like what a recommended portion
of this and then you go,
you're like,
oh,
that's not bad.
That's normal.
I was just eating too much of it to your
protein.
You want to be on like if you want to
do,
you're trying to do a fat burning
ketogenetic diets.
I think they say it's 75 percent,
75 percent fats and then the rest is
like 20 percent proteins,
like five percent carbs,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's right.
Something.
Is that what it is?
That's about it.
Yes.
Somewhere around,
around those numbers.
But um,
we have one of those grab one of those
mile plex bags,
Jamie that we got in the back.
There's this new company,
not new companies,
old ass company.
They've been around forever that make a,
I have no affiliation with these people
and there's no ad.
It's like a friendly powder.
Yeah.
They make a like a pack and it's a Keto
meal that you could like shake it.
Like if you're on the go and you don't
want to fuck up and eat something.
See?
Yup.
I ordered these.
Yeah,
I got a sensitive don't they?
They don't taste bad,
so it's like 75 percent fat.
Twenty percent protein.
Five percent by the way,
it's a lot of powder.
If you try to put this in a ounces,
it's a fucking ton.
Yeah.
I put it in one of those Yeti tumblers
and I'm a mixed it up with carbonated
water,
like an asshole.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I was still stupid.
I.
Did you find that in there?
Did you see the Mug in there?
Um,
I uh,
got this new soda from this company
called [inaudible].
Have you ever had that shit?
Big Ad.
That's not an ad.
It's a,
they make soda with Stevia.
Oh,
okay.
So they have soda.
They have like energy drinks and then
they have this sparkling water says it's
good.
It's good.
I like Stevia.
If you like the flavor of Stevia,
it's good because it's kind of got to
like a flavor to it,
but it doesn't fuck with you,
you know,
like I still love a coca cola.
I mean I know it's kind of syrupy and
fucked up,
but you're eating ribs,
you know,
nothing better.
Come on son.
So that's one of them's a peach and one
of them is alive.
Those are the sparkling water ones.
So those are like very,
very mild.
And they have other ones that are like a
soda.
I'm gonna try one can open,
done,
get down with it.
Tommy pass me one of those bitches.
They got passed to try and I'm trying
mandarin orange.
I'm giving you lyme.
But.
And again this is not an ad folks,
so I don't,
but I think thanks to these super
important to just try just.
I mean even if it's a one time for a bet
like Tommy's doing it not bad,
just try to be healthy.
Try.
Yeah,
try.
Goddammit.
You'll feel better.
That's the thing is ultimately,
even if you don't get to like some crazy
level with your fantasy level of it,
you're still,
you're still doing better than you were.
You still will feel better.
You want to get down with the hulk
loads?
Yeah man,
I'm going to trust a Kale shake.
It's called the local clothes.
I remember.
I've heard that.
You got to try them.
You're going to drink it and you go holy
Shit.
Cause you have to kind of chew it as
you're swallowing it.
It's like a sludgy sort of a thing that
kind of choke it down and then we'll
work out.
We'll make a video.
Okay.
We'll do it and then we'll like 45
minutes later we'll work out.
You're going to be like,
Holy Shit.
Do I feel good?
A heavy bag.
I got that.
Okay,
let's do that.
I got heck squats.
Let's do that shit.
Ripped a elliptical.
How about we'll do that and then I'll do
your podcast.
Let's do it.
Switch it up.
Are you guys up and running?
And the new spa?
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
You enjoying it?
Love it.
Do you guys stream live?
No.
Do you?
You make videos and then you put it up
later.
We have,
we,
we have cameras.
We've had two cameras set up one camera
setup,
um,
where I give it to an editor afterwards
and he,
um,
he just layers up the uh,
the,
you know,
the high quality audio with the video
later.
What we put it up,
it goes up every Tuesday night.
Okay.
So tonight when will go up?
So are you guys doing one a week now?
Are you doing.
It's one a week every single year.
We do.
I mean it's pretty.
It sounds funny because we've talked
about like,
fucking,
it feels like there's not time to do
anything,
you know,
like we feel like it's a lot to get that
one done and there is a lot of
production and that like,
you know,
we play the clips and there's all that
stuff that goes into it and then we'll
talk about one is as demanding on us and
then we were like,
oh,
Joe did three,
three and a half hour ones this week.
Yeah.
But I'm super sloppy and I don't plan
out.
Well,
I'm just saying,
you know,
it ends up being,
they're totally in the end.
Like,
you know,
show is.
But yeah,
we do the one consistently.
Every single you have a show.
Yeah.
Do you mean your show is a real show?
This is like a recording of a
conversation.
That's true.
So you guys have like,
you have like a bunch of shit going on
that happens over and over again.
You have games you play.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's a different animal.
You're totally right.
Um,
but yeah,
it,
I love the new studio space is fucking
gorgeous.
We a film composers house,
so he used to score movies there and
when he got,
we have this much too nice a studio for,
for where we're doing our part show.
Do you guys have the kind of internet
where you could stream at a high level?
Uh,
yeah.
If we went,
um,
if we,
uh,
went hardwire.
Yeah,
we could do that.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's some benefit to that,
like there's a benefit to that if
anything is getting wacky.
Yeah.
You know,
in the world maybe you want to live.
Yeah.
Like Duncan and I,
once we streamed the president
addressing the country.
Do you still do ustream?
Oh No,
we just do youtube.
We're doing youtube right now.
Is Youtube live?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
it was just more versatile and it didn't
mess up as much.
We hit,
we had problems.
Yeah.
But I think ustream is better now,
but they're,
you know,
they're always up,
upgrading.
And it was great though.
I mean it's still,
it allowed us to do this in the first
place,
but also it's just a president for more
used by people.
Sure.
So we watched,
uh,
the president talk about Syria,
like Duncan and I watched it live and we
were talking about it live while it was
happening,
almost like a fight companion.
Sure.
Presidential address.
And it was just real weird man,
because Viken pains are massive.
Right.
If those go nuts,
those are fun as hell.
Yeah.
This is a really fun to do.
But every time we do them,
Eddie Bravo gets drunk and wants to talk
about the Illuminati.
That's like half the fun of it.
The conversation goes everywhere.
But Eddie Bravo will always bring it
around to conspiracy theories.
He loves it.
Is he still onto the chem trails?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Aerosol spraying,
spraying,
which,
you know,
it's probably been done somewhere at one
point in time for sure.
Listen,
100 percent,
someone went on a plane and dumped some
shit out of the plane.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
The government's done it somewhere for
sure.
For sure.
There's probably some evil agency
somewhere that has decided to fucking
test out some shit on people.
Yep.
And there's been stuff that's been
proven that's been done,
like I want to say it was either Detroit
or Chicago,
I forget what it was,
but they,
um,
they sprayed some particles that they
could track,
they sprayed into the air and the city
to,
uh,
determine what kind of impact a bomb.
Like a dirty bomb.
Yes.
Alright.
Allowed biological warfare,
something along those lines.
Either a nuclear nuclear fallout or
biological warfare,
like how far it would travel given like
a certain amount of wind.
So I think they actually like use
giant fans and shit and blew some stuff
in there and then tracked it.
But let's see how many people get sick.
How did that though they didn't,
they didn't,
they?
No,
no,
no.
That's where the misconception is.
I think what they did was a truck,
they used a trackable particle because
they wanted to figure out how much.
The only way to find out,
let's say the wind is blowing 20 miles
an hour,
some shake gets blown up 200 miles or
200 feet rather above the buildings.
How far is it going to spread?
You know,
if you're looking at that,
the only way to tell us to try out
something.
So they took some sort of,
I think it was like a reflective
particle or traceable particle.
So conspiracy theories,
theories always pointed that as being
like proof that they have done that on
innocent people.
Sure.
Which they definitely did.
I mean,
I don't know what happened to those
people,
but she had happens to people all the
time.
If you're too close to this or too close
to that and then they find out,
oh yeah,
that kills you.
Turns out,
turns out you can't do that.
Yeah.
Unreal.
Turns out you can't eat paint.
A lot of people do dumb shit.
Yeah.
Dude.
Did you see that video I put up with
that kid doing the fucking front flip
over this gigantic overpass.
I saw you have some dude on top of a
building doing retarded shit.
I've done though.
I mean I put those up.
I put them up every time I can,
but I,
I posted this one of this fucking kid.
He goes running up to the side of this
edge and then flips over this impossible
distance.
I mean,
it's fucking impossible.
How far he runs.
Watch this.
Oh my God.
Come on.
Yup.
That's not really 100 percent real real.
Don't look at them.
Do it
dude.
He did a front flip over a and that's
death.
Like if you missed,
that's death.
You hit that concrete.
You break your legs.
That's dead.
Fuck me man.
These kids are crazy.
They're doing the nuttiest shit lately.
It's like white people are trying to
evolve.
They're trying.
Why?
People are trying to trying to get like
crazier and fast,
Bro.
We need our edge.
Why?
People are doing ridiculous things.
Has got the numbers blacks have there
because this guy,
he's riding a rail over the side of a
bridge and the wind is blowing and he's
on a bike.
Why in the fuck is going through your
mind while you are risking certain death
just slightly to the left of you and
you're writing on it.
What does that three inches.
How wide is that?
Three inches.
About size of your Dick and about three
inches.
I'm aware of to in Jersey.
Yeah.
No,
I'm definitely thinner.
I'm thin and curly like a duck stick.
Man Goes around and around.
Have you ever seen a domestic?
Uh,
haven't.
I think I've seen the pigs.
Dick Ducks,
ducks.
My friend Andrea is Antonopoulos is
bitcoin expert.
Explained to me about Duck Dick's.
He gave me slightly wrong information.
He said there were like four feet long.
It turns out they are about 13 inches
long now.
It's a big old Dick.
Big Hog.
Yeah.
They have these crazy dicks and their
dicks or like when they extended out
there like almost as long as their body.
It's really weird.
And these ducks,
they're dicks are twisty and the female
duck's vagina is like a fucking twisty
mountain road.
And I'm like,
he's gotTa.
Find a way in tick in there and the
female can let him in.
That's what their Dick looks like.
Yeah.
That's one.
Obviously with no duck,
it's a homeless stick,
but that's what I believe that not
insane.
The pictures of these ducks that,
that's,
that's a little bit.
I'm a little bit exaggerated because
it's an illustration that's a real
delicate corkscrew.
That one's obviously he's dead,
so it's probably not hard,
but it's this crazy weird thing where
the male penis has to go through this
weird kind of twisty turny corridor in
the female duck and the female doc can
decide to let them in or not.
She just shut them down and they're
super rapey like,
look at that one white one on top of the
other one.
That one bird.
Look at that.
That's really good.
That's what they do.
They just jack each other.
Yeah.
It looks like he's talking shit too.
He's right over here and we can look at
them and we could say,
oh,
that's rude.
That's horrible.
Why don't we stop and pause and realize
this is the same fucking kind of animal
that we just saw swooped down and Jack
that other fucking bird right out of a
tree.
Look what distance do you think he saw
that bird from when he decided I will go
a long way.
They could probably see like a mile that
far.
Yeah,
they probably could see ridiculous
distances.
There's a lot of animals that could see
ridiculous distances.
A Turkey apparently hasn't seen vision.
They see a Turkey ever looked through
binoculars like you ever been glass.
And I have,
I've glass before.
Yeah.
Well let me give you some glass in
knowledge.
Tommy,
your average,
uh,
the average binoculars had a hunter or
sportsmen or a birdwatcher will taking
the woods.
Like there's a bunch of varieties for
hunting.
Usually people either go with like 10 by
42 or eight by 42.
It's like eight times the size and 42 is
like the aspect ratio,
right?
The width of the image that you're
looking at a term,
like a good pair of binoculars,
just like a 10 by 42.
But Turkey naturally sees 20 x.
So a Turkey naturally sees 20 times
better than you.
Really?
Yep.
And they see in full color.
So they could see you,
they see you,
they see you better than you see you.
So you like literally have to be
completely covered up.
If you want to hunt Turkeys,
you have to cover your face up,
you have to cover your hair on that
head.
And look right at you.
They know this person.
Let me get the fuck out of here.
Like they see you from way off.
Wow.
Because Turkey,
the life of a Turkey.
So brutal Mo.
Most turkeys don't get to be too.
Most of Them.
Yeah.
Most of them that survive at all.
Like when they're little coyote jack.
I'm not that kind of vision.
Insane vision.
Yeah.
And saying my vision has been
deteriorating onto.
I started wearing reading glasses.
Me too.
Yeah,
it's brutal.
My dad glasses.
Yeah.
I just accepted it.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm not fighting.
It is what it is.
Apparently there's some exercises that
you can do to get better at it,
but I'm so lazy.
People don't want you to do lasik.
No,
because lasik doesn't work on soMeone
who has macular degeneration.
Like when you get older,
like you,
the what,
what you're having.
When you get older,
when you're losing your close vision,
you know,
it's like you're,
you're,
I forget.
Somebody told me the actual term of it.
Like mY friend steve who's an
ophthalmologist,
he actually told me the term of it,
my,
a macular degeneration.
Maybe look up treatments for macular
degeneration and laser therapy is one
can have injections.
Google,
um,
instead of that google near sightedness
due to old age and he didn't know the
solutions with the latest technology is
by the way,
for guys are going to give you eyes.
You can stare straight in the sand.
Phenologist told me he was part of the
team that developed it.
They so lenses is corrective lenses into
your eyes now.
Are you done with that?
No,
he was just.
He told me.
I don't know.
He goes,
you don't need it.
but if you had worse vision is
definitely something we could do.
Here's the thing,
like when you look at it,
something like I see you perfectly.
I mean if I put glasses on,
like I'll probably see you a little
better.
Like let me say a slightly.
You gotta like a light dullness to you.
I put the personality wise.
Personality is amazing.
A lot of people have been shitting on
you lately.
I don't know why he,
man.
That's one of the backhand and fuck with
your head competencies.
A lot of people say,
you suck.
I don't agree at aLl.
I think you're amazing.
I always had like,
hey,
what the fuck dude?
But I'm up close.
Big difference.
Like in it at a distance I could see
crystal clear like that sign it says on
air,
I see that it's very sharp,
but when I look at things like on my
phone,
same way man breeding computer that used
to be able to read it perfectly snuck up
on me,
man snuck up on me.
Some people say it's from staring at
screens.
Some people say it's just a function of
being older.
Yeah,
some people say that it is a combination
of factors,
but also one thing that doesn't help is
that we constantly staring at something
that's a fixed distance.
Right.
And the way some people put it as that.
It's like,
who was the woman?
Katie bowman,
katy bowman.
When she was on the podcast,
she.
She's an expert in human movement and
she believes she's got a lot of pretty
nutty ideas.
Like they don't use furniture.
They sleep on the floor there and she
thinks that like looking at something
that's like really close distance is
like having a cast for your eyes,
almost like you need to put your arm in
a cast.
It atrophies because you're not using it
the right way.
And we've been,
yeah,
we've been looking at screens.
That's not a bad theory.
At least doing.
I got super big ones and aubrey and I
did a podcast.
I went off on this tangent that's been
fucking with me ever since we were
talking about screens that if you looked
at human beings and if you didn't know
anything about us and be like,
oh,
they worshiped the screens because all
we do,
you get up in the morning,
you check your phone,
you check your email,
you go to work,
you stare at your screen and the
computer in a cubicle.
You come home,
you watch a little tv,
you go on the weekend.
Now we're going to go see a flick your
staring at screens like if something
that didn't understand something that
didn't understand what what those images
were or didn't care or was trying to
Judge you based on entirely on your
actual movement and interaction,
they'd be like,
oh my god,
they're slave to the screen like they
don't even understand.
We have to get It in these screens
pulled.
We're slaves to watching these screens.
If you stop and think about how often
you spend your time staring at a screen,
it's significant.
It's giant.
It's hours and hours of almost
everybody's life.
When you read that way,
it's depressing.
It's really depressing.
It's weird.
It's weird because it's not staring at
the screen.
We're watching westworld.
I'm checking my twitter.
I'm checking my email or taking a photo.
I'm going to put it on instagram.
Let's make a video.
Hey,
let's make a video.
You eating the kale shake.
Let's put it on youtube,
but what's ultimately going on is people
are interacting with screens to get all
this energy and you want a better screen
all the time.
You want to constantly have this bitch
faster and upgraded and it wants to do
more things and now it's virtual.
Now he can get the screen and it's in
your head.
He could see 360 degrees all around you
and then it's just more and more and
more screens.
All rIght man.
You fucking scared me or use happiness.
Bark this joint back.
Oh my god.
Freaking myself out,
bro.
You worry about screens.
Tommy,
what about them haunting?
You know,
they call you at night.
Check your phone.
No,
I want to be in swimming.
He might've texted.
I want to be screened to now.
I do look at screens.
I get Yelled at for checking the phone
too much and I do like proud of myself
today.
Just checkin.
I left mY phone in the car when I took
my yoga class.
And then you ran out to it afterwards?
Yeah.
Check.
yeah,
sure.
Some new crazy shit's on in the world.
It's addictive.
So addictive.
It's a real addiction too.
So I see it.
It's a,
and I always talked about were at
restaurants,
you know,
and you see the family together and then
you're looking at my family that he had,
that kid was looking at me because the
kid is like the net.
There's no interaction at the table.
Well,
when,
when we're at all bullshit aside,
when they get tired,
like when kids get tired,
yeah,
this is what you find to not kill that
and especially if you want to have a
conversation with,
it's not a bad thing to occasionally and
let them look at an ipad or play a game.
Like if it's on a plane or something
like that.
but oftentime often oftentimes you can
get the same kid like as in gay
especially.
they like books.
Yeah.
Just give them a book to read.
So instead of sitting there playing a
game,
which is kind of mindless,
they're reading a book which can kind of
expand their imagination.
However,
there Is also some arguments against
that.
It's mindless because there's a lot of
arguments about video games that all the
video games are kind of problematic for
little kids because they do.
They do just become super addictive.
They also can expand your mind
and they're also.
There's examples of people that have
done tests that have shown that video
games actually can make you smarter
because they make you constantly
exercising parts of your brain and solve
problems.
I don't doubt that at all.
I mean,
like I,
I hadn't won the game.
Right.
It depends on the game.
Depends on.
Yes,
on the system.
Maybe you know,
but like there's definitely games you
can play where I feel like there's
something going on in your brain when
you're efficient,
you're prolific,
you're,
you're at a higher level performing in
that game where if you put somebody
slower into the same game,
they can't do it.
You know,
like they,
they're not Moving at that.
There's a cerTain.
I'm not saying that that means you're
going to be great at everything,
but there's something in your brain
functioning,
moving well to be able to put together
how to,
how to play this game and play it really
high level.
Yeah man.
There's people that there are people you
can teach.
I mean,
have you ever tried to show someone how
to play a game and they just can't get
it?
Can't get it to do it or they don't have
any desire so they never tried.
Yeah,
I mean I've seen people try,
which I think stands out more.
They just are not good at it.
You know,
you go,
you need a lot more practice,
whereas some people can just pick up,
you know,
and be.
And I think those people come from a
world of playing growing up,
right?
Like imagine today's kid who's born now
playing like that.
These level gaMes that are out now,
how you know how he's going to be fluent
in that whole technology cyber stuff in
15,
20 years.
Yeah.
You got to work them through it,
right?
Yeah.
Like my six year olD is just now
figuring out that you can't beat me and
tic tac toe really just like this
motherfucker.
I can't beat him.
I'm like,
you're never going to win.
I go,
it's going to be a drive every time.
Really?
Yeah.
she's like,
wow.
I go,
because this is a dumb game.
It's a dumb game that puzzles You when
you're young,
but as you get older you realize tic tac
toe is fucking stupid.
Unless you could make two moves in a
row,
it's fucking dumb,
you know,
because you do this.
Oh,
I'm going to saY you're going to go over
here,
so I'll do that.
I'll do that.
And you do thIs.
Oh well I'm going to go over here so you
can't do that.
And then I'll draw this draw you draw
every time.
Every time.
And you know,
I,
I've been there before,
but now I offer a,
some sort of a path,
like think about what's going on here.
She goes,
oh yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I give her a little pause.
I don't go,
oh,
you fucked up,
right?
You suck.
You don't try to teach her along the way
because she's only 16.
She's 16 and I'm still kicking her ass
to tic tac toe.
Listen,
dummy.
Waste tuition was the only way someone
beats you at tac is if you're not paying
attention.
Right?
True.
Yeah.
You have to miss out if you're keyed
into it.
Unless there's some crazy moves and I
don't know about.
I haven't played in awhile,
so it's hard to say.
Actually.
Is there a world tic tac toe
championship?
I'm sure there is.
If you had to guess.
Yes.
How smart is the person that won a
fucking genius?
Stephen hawking levels.
Shit.
Lucy.
He playing for neil tyson.
Imagine neil degrasse tyson and richard
dawkins take.
What do you say that at the end of tick
tack toe.
Forget.
Is that supposed to be the call the to
say tic tac toe guests,
but nobody ever does.
It's like trick or treat the little
fuckers.
just show up with open bags.
Put it in man.
You got snickers like.
It's weird when you see that one kid
that's just a little too old for trick
or treat.
It starts to get creepy.
It's like trick or treating is fun.
How do you put in your name?
Give them candy.
NobodY.
Do you um,
have everyone come to the front door,
do you the end thing?
Yeah,
they ring doorbells and um,
you know,
we go walking around the neighborhood
too.
It's fun.
It's a designated.
Didn't love it.
No halloween.
Well no.
Um,
some,
some places like they do at like,
you know,
there's like the day before,
if it's like,
depending on the day of the week,
you know,
he can't do that now.
You've got to do halloween when it's
halloween.
Your mother fuckers.
I haven't been out trying to take over
America.
There's a coup goIng on.
Have you been paying attention?
The russians have canceled halloween.
I just thought about how dumb I go.
So would you have a day that you do it?
Hell,
fuck it all the way.
This pot man,
god damn pot.
It's terrible for you.
Terrible mAn.
Just makes you dumb.
It makes you ask questions you should
have thought through.
Like,
what day is halloween?
Same day.
Every year.
That's a weird thing about thanksgiving.
Thanksgiving is not the same day every
year,
right,
because it's on thursday always.
Right,
so the the number,
right?
The date is always that third thursday.
Is it kind of stupid shit?
Is that.
Why is it fucking thursday?
Why are you pretending that those
goddamn pilgrims ever sat down with
those native americans like that?
That shit didn't happen.
They didn't even speak the same
language.
Those original people that landed,
if you ever read some of the accounts at
christopher columbus is atrocities that
he committed and I know that there's a
lot of people that are appalled by a
day.
I think it's an outrageous.
Do you ever think about what you learned
in school about thanksgiving?
How nice.
They made it to have a native american
day,
but we have a columbus day.
It's really outrageous.
Yeah.
I know.
And thanksgiving they used to be like
and then this guy was like,
are you eating alone?
Sit over here.
And then that's how they became best
friends.
Like that's how they taught.
They taught us in school and they hate
Turkey and then they were like,
even though you're different,
let's all hang out.
Let me say something.
They weren't shooting merriam turkeys.
Turkeys didn't know any better.
Right?
Like as soon as the turkeys figured out
what the fuck they were doing,
they were like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
you can't do.
You can't shoot us like that.
We're just going to fly away over that
metal.
Like,
yeah,
dad,
those shitty guns bills must get guns.
They had those flints and shit.
Yeah.
Those things were inaccurate.
Push it down.
We're not in the distance.
I mean,
I don't know how far they could shoot
those things,
but they were shooting deer most likely
they were eating deers.
Yeah.
Thanksgiving.
You fucking purge,
right?
It should be just a bloodbath.
Holiday.
You get to kill her buddy.
It's thanksgiving just
like our ancestors did.
Well,
it's not our ancestors.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Mine came over in a boat pretty
recently,
like I could try.
Fine.
Yeah.
So if anybody says like,
hey,
you man,
you know your ancestry.
Ah,
nope.
They didn't do anything.
Didn't own any slaves.
Came over from Italy and the 19 hundreds
I tracked mine back to 17 hundreds.
That's when they came over here.
Oh yeah,
you're a killer.
You're all families responsible for
atrocities.
This guy actually,
we got a report on him at a family
reunion.
Oh shit.
We had this guy who came over.
Yeah.
What was he like?
I say he's a real piece of shit.
It kind of ruined the family reunion.
It was not real cool.
Murdered somebody.
It was a spanish guy came from under
lucila and he,
uh,
yeah,
he really said,
you know,
they read his,
um,
his will and they're like it.
Then he left 30 slaves to this person.
We don't want to get another drink.
This is getting uncomfortable like that.
And then they said he killed somebody in
Louisiana and they're like any hung
someone from this tree.
And it was like a,
like a real savage dude.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's in your blood and you're the
nicest guy ever.
I know.
Had that happened,
I don't know,
but you know,
that's my granddad.
Great granddad or granddad.
Oh no,
this is like great.
Great,
great,
great.
Like,
I'm like,
damn,
how old are your people live?
Not 10 greats,
man.
It's,
it's super removed from me.
Like,
that's amazing.
Your people live forever.
No,
this guy would be come over and like
early,
early 17 hundreds.
It's so weird to think that a human
being gets.
If there were super,
super lucky,
they get like 90 years of life and while
that life is going on,
you're just trying to figure out what's,
what's happening,
what are you doing?
Like what are,
why are we gathering together in these
cities?
Why are we going to work?
Why are we going home and going to
sleep?
Why are we doing this?
Like,
what are we doing?
Why are we staring at screens?
Why am I bringing slaves?
Did you ever think about like as you get
older,
staying like as a funny comic,
you know what I mean?
Did you ever that ever occur to you?
What does that mean?
Like there's a like maybe you should try
to be funny.
Maybe we should play them up being
funny.
No,
my thing is about being a february.
So I'm saying that like in general we
have this sort of outlook that being
funny.
Comedy in general I'm saying is a
younger person's kind of thing,
right?
It's,
it's up until a certain age.
Yes.
What does that age as well?
It's like there's really funny guys that
are 60,
like ron white,
hundred percent men.
I totally agree.
I'm saying like,
has it ever like.
Did you ever think as you get like as
you're going through your forties,
like am I still in that circle?
I mean it sounds like lame to say it,
but like,
cool,
funny as opposed to like,
oh,
that's an older guy is older,
you know,
like do you ever process that as you age
or.
No,
it's never like a methodical thought,
you know?
Well I try not to think like that
because that doesn't seem to have
upside.
Yeah.
That seems like a very limiting thought
and there's nothing you can do about it
if you are an older person.
But to mitigate it was different.
To cut that off at the path.
Yeah.
I just try to do my best.
So I feel like if you're living your
life and you're in the moment,
you try and do your best and obviously
you're gonna follow that back and forth
and left and rIght.
You're gonna have good days and bad
days,
like when you have a mindset or if
you're trying to trying to do your best
at something or trying to,
uh,
enjoy your life in a,
you know,
like a balanced,
happy way.
It's not always super smooth path,
you know,
there's a lot of mistakes and hiccups
along the way.
And the whole thing is it's about like
having an idea of what you're trying to
do,
have an idea of how you're trying to
live and how you want to feel and how
you want to affect people.
And then sort of like figuring out your
way through that path.
And then as you keep doing it,
you keep getting better at it.
Sure.
And I think that if that's the case,
if you're living your life like that,
if you're trying to make.
I'm trying to make this path through
your existence,
it will at least leave you in a place
where your.
You're constantly trying to have fun and
you're constantly trying to improve and
I think you'll get like
feelings out of it.
But at the end of the day,
it's still the same thing.
It's still this strange temporary
existence where you're awake and
conscious for a certain amount of time
everyday,
but then your unconscious for a certain
amount of time every day and you're
ultimately going to shut off.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's all gonna go down no matter what
you're doing.
But I was looking at these photos of
like red buttons wound a Jerry Lewis at
these events like uh,
you could buy a ticket to.
Okay.
So when they get become undeniably older
comics.
Right.
And I saw the audience was all very old
and I wondered,
I wondered like is this a,
is this a thing that happened at a
moment like george carlin was 70 and
still drawing in young guys?
Absolutely.
I understand for other.
So some women too.
That's a great counter to it.
But my thought was,
so is it that those guys,
what I'm saying,
stop being funny to a certain generation
or they stopped trying or they just got,
I don't know,
so old,
you know,
it could be a bunch of those things.
It could be taken care of your health.
It could be.
I'm touring and working a lot.
George carlin was touring constantly.
Constantly.
Yeah.
He will put out a whole new hour every
year.
Unbelievable.
And he was still really funny at 70,
like,
and he also had taken on the role of the
angry curmudgeon,
you know,
this,
this angry older comic who's also very
wise and very liberal.
I love that character.
Yeah.
I mean I love the liberal pretty
fascinating guy and stayed relevant,
relevant rather to the very end of his
life and died like I believe in a hotel
room after a show.
Yeah.
I think he died in his.
I think it was one of those things.
And that's hard to crazy diddy.
Yeah,
I remember he went to,
I want to say a santa monica hosPital.
Well he had um,
he had uh,
issues with pills too,
man.
Yeah.
He was pretty forthcoming about that.
Some code problems from earlier.
Yeah.
That all that shit contributes the pills
or the most shocking.
The way they deteriorate people.
Yeah.
He was so funny at 70 then he was so
funny and I think that,
that dude was still killing.
Yeah.
So are you thinking about this now
because you're a father now and you're
thinking you're getting older,
you get into your forties.
It's one of those things that um,
what I,
what I actually think is that,
like I,
I'll think about that I'll look at,
but you know,
people older than me then one of the
things that I find inspiring is that I
feel like people at the top of their
game in stand up right now are
essentially all 10 to 15 years older
than me.
So I fiNd that to be a very,
like,
I'm inspiring thought,
you know,
like everybody is like late forties,
early fifties,
and you're like,
oh,
it just one of those things you go like,
you can be better,
you can,
you can still do greater things.
Be funny,
Like develop more into your forties.
Whereas I think as a young comic,
when you're 20,
all you hear about is like 10 years,
10 years,
10 years.
So you go,
that's must be the place to get to 10
years.
So when I'm 30,
that'll be my development.
But you realize you can keep working.
We'll also,
you're,
when you're thinking about the body of
standing up that's been before you,
there's so many great comedians that
have done so many great cds and dvds and
all these different things.
One of the things that separates you
from maybe a guy that lived 20 years ago
as a,
you're also like playing off the body of
work of all these people that came
before you.
True because they set this bar right.
You've been inspired by their comedy and
been inspired by you know,
movies and all sorts of different pop
culture things that just didn't exist 20
years ago.
So you have a greater points of
reference.
True.
You know?
Yeah.
and I think as you get older you have a
better understanding of all the shit
you're looking at.
So you might be able to point things out
like as you're in your forties that
maybe you wouldn't have never even seen
when you're in your thirties because
you're tripping over your own deck and
yeah,
being a dumb ass and sure you know,
and you did.
Didn't you or understanding of the world
then would embarrass you today.
Which sometimes it does,
just for sure for everybody.
There's no,
there's no doubt about it.
Unless you were born in the perfect
person,
you're a work in progress.
If you have any self reflection,
you look back and you're like,
I can't live with that,
but that's just a matter of getting
better at life.
But there's aLso nothing wrong with
being Jerry Lewis or red buttons are in
guys and just kill,
kill,
killing time when you get older and
hanging out and just stopping the grind.
I was thinking about that just in the
shower the other day.
Like I,
I'd seen a picture of that and I was
like,
I'm going to be 80 in my fucking red
jacket.
Yeah.
I fucking know kilroy and I'm to go and
my fans will be like the fans that saw
me 50 years ago and I'll just be in
there like rodney.
Yeah man.
And I was actually,
I was actually happy with that thought
too.
Yeah,
that's a good thought.
Yeah.
You can't freak on that man.
It is what it is.
It might not even be real.
You might wake up tomorrow exactly the
same age and the,
you might be programmed with this,
uh,
intermittent memory that every time you
wake up,
you pretend that you have this past that
you're trying to get better than.
But the reality is this,
this same day has always been your life.
How are you fucking with over and over
and over again?
It's everything that's happened other
than this moment.
This conversation has been bullshit.
It's all just been fiber optically
implanted into the grain in the back of
your ear.
Does jamie press a button and then this
happens.
This is What happening with trump.
When trump became president,
and then when kanye west was a fresh
three or four days out of the loony bin
goes to visit tropic trauma.
It's like,
yeah,
sure.
It's an intimate.
Not like I'm the president and you're
crazy.
Come on him and him and Donald Trump,
apparently very good friends.
I saw that.
It's wonderful.
I love that.
I love friendship.
Trump said he doesn't read the daily
presidential briefings because you
probably shouldn't.
He's a genius.
He's.
What the fuck does he need a daily
presidential briefings?
That's our president of folks,
dah,
dah.
Have you seen the saturday night live
sketch?
They did.
How a Donald Trump views the world now.
It's fucking hilarious.
I've seen a couple of things.
Take it as a joke.
I hope he doesn't get too mad.
I just.
One problem with that dude is that,
uh,
he doesn't take jokes.
Right?
Well,
he gets real upset.
I think he's going to learn,
man.
This kind of lighten up can be a long
four years,
bro.
And he was better.
I'm Jeff Ross had them.
They roasted them.
I remember.
And Jeff Ross had a conversation with
them.
It's like,
well,
you know,
when people were cracking jokes by.
Yeah,
we turned the camera to you did.
It looks like you're a bad sport.
Like you're not laughing along.
He's like,
you're right.
So you started laughing.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So he's,
he's not.
He listened.
He gets it.
Nothing is unreceptive,
but when he sees this side out,
live one's going to be rough.
Yeah.
He got mad at the last few years.
He's been mad at sarah live for awhile
and so they keep chipping away at them,
but this is like the best saturday night
live has been in fucking years.
Horace mann,
you have somebody did fucking go after
it.
It's fantastic.
And you've got Alex Baldwin willing to
do it.
He's like an oscar winner.
I think so.
Tremendous actor.
How is he at glare gun ross if he didn't
win an oscar?
Fuck the astros.
Now.
He's tremendous actor.
Some people say that was overdone.
I don't like that scene.
I just thought it was too over the top.
That's not how people would behave.
It's a fucking stage play.
He's to say that though.
You ever see that?
Some actors think he tried too hard to
find.
They don't like it.
Go away too actory too.
Actory.
I've heard people say that.
I've seen people over.
She's just too big.
What they're doing is too big.
It's not our show.
He should have been big right there.
This is not what we're looking for.
Yeah.
Wants to be more grounded.
That's the word.
Yeah,
but alec baldwin is the fucking perfect.
Donald trump.
He's fantastic and it's really fucking
funny.
Also,
alec baldwin really understands what
it's like to be a cunt.
Yeah,
right.
Although I don't think he's a cunt.
He definitely has had moments in his
life where he's been accused of being.
I can't attack proper razzies.
He's a wacky dude.
He.
He got punched somebody or something.
He got accused of killing a paparazzi,
a fag.
ThIs was my favorite,
and then he goes.
I called him a fat head because it's
kind of an audible.
Right,
becauSe he's screaming down the street.
He's like I said,
fat head.
more fat shaming.
Yes.
Like what you said,
but I also.
Oh yeah.
He called his daughter who was 11 or
rude.
Thoughtless pig.
yeah,
that was the big one.
That was.
That's,
that's hard.
You know what man?
People fuck up.
Yeah,
but you can't.
What are you?
Gonna punish forever for that too.
Like that's terrible that he did that.
It really is.
Don't you think he feels like he feels
that after people heard that he's been
forgiven by hollywood.
You feel like shit after that.
Yeah,
it's awful.
That was my.
Actually,
my first was my first words,
my mother when I was a baby.
It's awful.
No,
I said you were a road thoughtless pig.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
You just formed that sentence like,
I know.
What was it that you were like stewing
on until your lips form correctly so you
can make good noises?
I think it's just she wasn't feeding me
enough.
You know?
It's just happened,
man.
Yeah.
It's.
Imagine if babies could talk right out
of the box,
man.
If they had a full vocabulary,
the on the line right there would be so
stupid.
They don't know full babies.
They'd be like,
monster.
I'm a monster dummy.
And we dad,
they would do everything.
They would also be like,
I'm going to eat this.
Everything would be like know,
like no plastic.
No,
no.
Eat hair rock.
Can I stick my finger inside that light
socket?
Know what if I turned it on?
No.
And no.
Becomes Like,
this is going to be fucking awesome.
That's what they do.
Know what my six year old loves to tell
me.
Can I tell you something right before
she's going to tell me something?
Yeah,
she goes,
can I tell you something?
It's always kind of tell you Something
that's fun,
you know?
Yeah.
Can I tell you something?
Debbie told this girl that she shouldn't
do that because she wasn't allowed and
it wasn't true.
And what do you do?
You go,
whoa.
Yeah.
It was the kind of conversation you have
With six year olds.
Like,
wow,
why wasn't she allowed?
Because her mother doesn't want her to
do it,
but she doesn't want to listen to her
mother.
Whoa,
that's crazy outrage in kindergarten.
Really funny.
That's their world.
Know that's life.
I know that his life,
you've got to respect that.
That's what's weird.
You know,
they get upset,
they get upset if you don't want to
listen to their wacky stories,
like the fucking boring story.
One of the things I've been teaching my
kids lately is don't repeat punchlines
over and over and over again,
because when they nail punch lines,
sometimes they'll say something really
funny and I said,
listen,
that's really funny.
You said it was really.
It was really funny.
I'm so like,
I'm so impressed.
He said something that was out fighting.
It's really funny,
but here's the thing,
if you say it again becomes less funny
and if you say it,
it gets even less funny.
Like every time you repeat it.
I know it's fun to say something funny.
You want to do it,
but I'm like,
unless you're doing a new show the next
night in new town kit or the same time
they get that crowd.
Yeah,
kinda getting it.
But it's,
you know,
it's touchy,
right?
Yeah.
Because you don't want to discourage
anybody from saying something funny and
silly.
Sure.
Like they make each other laugh all the
time.
They make me laugh.
We have these funny conversations.
It's funny having like joke
conversations where they're like
cracking me up and they're eight.
Yeah.
Because like in my,
in my house,
like you're like head writer and stuff.
Yeah.
Goofing on stuff is valuable.
It's valuable.
So like I mean invaluable in terms of
like social commodity,
like it's,
it's hilarious.
Like when one of them will say something
funny and we all laugh,
you could see the little eyes light up
and then they want to make you laugh
more.
You know,
and it's also when you find out things
that make people laugh,
you find out things that are ridiculous
that no one's talking about.
Like that's part of part of what's
funny.
When when kids point something out,
I was like,
yeah,
duh.
Fucking six year old notices that
stupid.
Like they tap into something like my
daughter was looking at one of those fat
freeze billboards.
You'll see that fat freeze billboard.
This is when she was five.
She goes,
I know that's fake because that girls
pulling in a stoMach.
Oh right.
Oh that's cute.
She's sucking her stomach in and she's
not even tricking a five year old.
That's hilarious.
but when she would she say it to me,
I'm fucking crying,
laughing and you see your little eyes
light up because the way she said I
didn't do a good justice with the
delivery.
Sure.
But she was like cocky about it.
I know that.
And then she kicked out that you're
lying.
She thinks it's so funny.
She's like,
she's holding the stomach.
Look at a daddy.
So holding in the stomach like a five
year old can see that nobody's stands
like this.
Yeah.
So you know,
kylie jenner sued those people who made
that because that girl in the sign
looked like her.
Oh really?
Yeah,
they do that.
They've done that before we can sue
someone for looking like you.
Kim kardashian turned down some campaign
and so they hired a kim kardashian look
alike and she sued them and won.
I think she won,
didn't she?
When jamie told larry said,
fucking five,
5:00
bed.
Shoot.
Where you going home?
Time to show tonight.
I shows at eight.
What time should I leave?
Jesus christ should have already left
your fuck dude.
I get going.
I got to get the past dean in three
hours.
and also the show.
Who's opening for you?
Doug mellard.
Really funny guy.
Really funny guy from austin.
Lives here.
Real funny.
How long has he been here?
did I meet him?
You may have met him.
He's been here for awhile.
He's been doing standup awhile and um,
I've had brought them with me a few
times.
He's really funny.
Dude.
this is like a feeling that you get when
someone says there's a really funny guy
from austin.
You go,
oh,
he's probably cool.
Yeah,
he's pretty cool.
He doesn't really cool vests.
No,
no.
He doesn't have.
He's a but he's.
He's a very funny guy.
Dresses like a mumford and sons.
Yes.
Like the mood music videos.
He looked like he'd be in the band.
Was a piano in the middle of a field for
no fucking reason.
We're all dancing around it.
He's got just like funny,
ironic tattoos and shit.
Oh,
does he?
Yeah.
He's got a few.
Keep on trucking.
You know,
has keep on trucking on time.
Canadian have some facility,
one like that too.
Does he?
I think he does get some.
He has some silly ones.
Yeah.
No attached yet.
No.
Are you thinking about getting
something?
No.
just don't have.
I mean I would if I had a fucking desire
to interest,
but I don't.
How about this?
Let's go chain across your belly.
Dude.
Let's Go champ.
How great was that?
Above that?
Right across your belly.
Like compton.
This.
Let's go champ.
Yeah.
How the fuck does no one have that?
Jamie,
please look up.
See if anyone has.
Let's go champ.
Tattooed on their belly.
They must.
That's bad ass did.
They should totally have.
That's dope.
That is a dove at champ and it was given
to me by shannon mechanics.
No,
he's a great guy,
man.
He's a fun dude.
Like real positive and I didn't see the
episode.
I didn't listen to it,
but um,
I saw his instagram preparing to come
here and that got me fired up like in.
Oh yeah.
It was like putting blue man.
he's going to wash them,
man.
I was fired up.
I'm Going to angeles.
Yeah,
that was awesome.
he's awesome man.
That was so fun for me to be sitting
across from him.
That's my,
that's my ring tone now.
Is it?
That's right.
Bitch.
Fucking amazing.
Yeah.
We've got to figure out a way to set
that up.
But jamie isolated that form of calls.
I would keep that for years.
That's fantastic.
That is fantastic.
I remember I'll probably watch the first
video is up and I knew shannon,
I was a fan of his as a boxer for a long
time,
but when I watched that video of him I
was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Like,
what is he doing?
Like this is interesting.
Those are cinderblocks.
Oh,
he's a big boy.
Quite a quite a large fellow.
When I hug them I'm like,
hi buddy.
My head nestle's next to his breasts.
That would hurt.
Well,
he's a big boxer.
He's big.
He's probably walking around in the to
50 range or to 40 range.
That connects with the chin.
Powerful punch room.
It's over.
Yeah.
He was a serious knockout puncher.
Shannon can crack.
He's also got this wicked left hook to
the body.
He's got a nasty jab,
but he's got this left hook to the body.
That's really rare to see in the
heavyweight division.
Yeah,
super quick.
Technical stabbing,
left hook.
Just black gets under your rib cage with
it.
He just dropped guys.
He's getting avoided.
A lot of people don't want to fight him.
Don't want a piece of that man.
Well,
he's a big guy,
he's a,
he's still real dangerous,
he's real motivated and he talks so much
shit.
He talked so much shit,
they can't take it in.
And the people that are,
they're going to these press conferences
with them and he's talking,
he's like yelling at them,
trying to get fights with them and
they're uh,
they're all at the press conference
announcing another fight and he's in the
audience.
He shows up.
Oh man.
He showed up at vladimir klitschkos,
uh,
was eaten lunch.
He started drinking his water and he
started eating his food.
yeah.
Yeah.
And when you,
we,
we helped us go champ,
you know,
shit.
Yeah.
And that was when I started being aware
of them and I was like,
my god,
he's crazy.
Like shannon briggs has gone crazy.
And then I realized,
oh,
he's just trying a new thing to make a
good get,
get guys to fight and make a name for
himself.
And he's really smart because he figured
out a way to use social media and he
completely changed how people thought of
him because people thought of them
before they knew about his personality.
They just thought he was this killer
boxer even talked about on the podcast.
He was like,
I just wasn't me because I was like,
just always,
you know,
be in this heavyweight knockout artist.
And he's a tough guy.
He's like,
I'm goofy.
He was like a goof around a lot.
I'm always joking around.
So you see that in those videos and
that's something that there was no other
way for him to ever show that key magic
hbo came to his house and like,
we want to watch it will workout.
Let's go champ,
let's go.
They were like,
cut all that out.
Just cut all that out.
Well then they would learn that that's
what's gonna make it a sensation,
a hit.
You know what?
I think he had to do it like over and
over and over and over and over again on
youtube and on instagram for people to
get addicted to it.
Because now like when I see it in my
feed and it's shannon's sitting in front
of like a bowl of food or something with
a big smile on his face,
I always click on other videos.
I want to hear it because it's,
it's,
it's him.
That's who he is.
I think that's one of the coolest things
about Your show that you have with you
and christina.
Your mom's house is you guys just
totally genuine.
That's 100 percent how you guys are all
the time.
That's true.
So like that's not available anywhere
else.
Like he can tell when something gets
popular,
you know,
or it gets a fan based.
It's because people connect to the
authenticity I think of,
of,
of people's real personalities.
Yeah man.
There's definitely that.
And there's also like,
there's,
there's less people from shannon doing
that.
There's almost no filters between him
and People.
There's less people involved.
Yeah.
So you could get to see this guy like
who he really is and there's so many
people like that now,
like joey diaz,
when jody is,
does those periscopes accuses?
It's beautiful because it's like
straight to joey,
this no one even around,
he gets some open number,
gets up in the morning,
it gives you like a few minutes notice
we're going live with smoking numbers
and then he gets on,
what did you do today?
And he starts talking about it.
It makes these tweets and the ridiculous
like,
you know,
it's monday,
you're showing up with a big dick and a
smile.
And I'm like,
okay,
I have a big deck,
but it's,
yeah,
people love that guy.
He's awesome.
But that's joey like,
you know,
you're getting joey,
100 percent joey spellings all fucked
up.
He has to indeed periods in a row.
It doesn't matter.
It's just you're getting straight joey,
you know,
and that's,
that's one of the more unique things
about this time and those goddamn
glasses that we were playing them.
When you,
when you went to pee,
they'll snapchat glasses.
Those things scare the shit out of me.
What are you aware of them?
And they snapchat everything.
Exactly of what we're talking about,
about recording memories.
You're going to record things that
people see.
This guy was doing a operation goggles
on and yeah,
it's just going to be able to stream
your life.
These things are cameras,
those things in the upper right hand
side are cameras and there was this
video that we were watching him,
this guy doing an operation,
cutting this person open while he's
wearing these snapchat glasses and it's.
It's so strange because you're realizing
like,
oh,
this is like the motorola razor.
This is like the motorola razor.
One day we're gonna have the iphone
seven.
I think it's crazy that we're talking
about $130.
I thought we were talking about some
really,
you know.
No,
no,
no.
And it streams snap for the staff chat
app.
And if you look at it this now come on
man.
This is like that fallen that kirk
douglas or Michael Douglas had in wall
street,
right?
That's basically what it is in
comparison to what they're going to have
just in a few years from now texting
people row,
but I gotta get.
I gotta get the fuck out of here and
wrap this up.
Unfortunately in it tommy bonds,
please do.
I have a tour coming up.
It's my first theater tour ever.
Shit,
by the way,
I just want to tell you very inspiring.
Watch you do that.
Set the other night in the main room
doing all new material that I haven't
seen before and it was really fun.
Thanks man.
Thanks.
That was really fun.
Thank you.
I've been working since,
you know,
the last one came out and I'm about at
an hour now and so the tour starts
january and going like coast to coast
Canada doing a bunch of bunch of dates.
Men.
YeAh,
we could tell.
You can tell.
You tell you're putting in the time.
That's,
you know,
that's one of the cool things about
being in la because I get to see so many
guys like you and joey
bar and ari and duncan and all these
guys that are just really fucking funny
in this one area.
Like all the time.
Yeah.
Great.
To see other people do like people you
people I love and that I look up to and
stand up.
Do sets regular here in crush,
you're like,
oh shit.
It always keeps you on your toes,
man.
Do.
The other night dave chappelle brought
up chris rock the store.
Get the fuck out of dodge.
He's going on a tour.
Not that he needs to fucking plug or
chris rock brought up.
Dave chappelle,
one of those,
but either way,
get the fuck outta here,
but that's a first tour in nine years
for rock divorce.
Divorce is a motherfucker.
Yeah.
It talks about it on stage tonight.
Gary,
did I tell you so I did a.
I opened for chappelle.
I did like it.
I shouldn't say,
oh,
did a 10 minutes set.
I stopped by his.
When I was in New York.
I stopped by his show.
Where was he?
He was at the grammercy.
Just four huNdred seat place.
Feels like doing it and it was before
snl,
but before they announced it,
so I was doing caroline's and I pop over
there and they're like,
oh yeah,
do time.
And he like,
just some time in I go to time,
I do like 10 minutes I get,
they don't see me.
THey're like,
fuck is dave chappelle,
so I get off.
He goes up and he starts doing this set
and then chris rock walks out and then
they pull up chairs and they basically
have a cow.
It's like a podcast.
It's basically a lab.
Ah,
a riff.
And they go
on shit.
And one point chappelle goes,
he's like,
you say like,
you say the wildest shit though to rock.
Yeah.
He's like,
what you mean man?
He said,
wow.
He saId,
he in chappelle goes,
you called me after your divorce and
said,
uh,
my wife has more comedy,
more money from,
from comedy than you do.
And I was like,
that's such a funny.
Chris rock said that to dave chappelle.
My wife has more money from comedy than
you do after divorcing.
Wow.
Like how funny though of a have a
thought about your situation?
You know,
that is a funny thought.
YeaH.
It's also a lot of money.
It must be insane.
Yeah.
Because chappelle's made a lot of
fucking money and rocks.
Yeah.
Well,
rock was probably one of the most
successful guys ever when he was doing
theaters like those.
I mean,
not theaters arenas and he was doing
world tours to.
I don't think that he did the hollywood
bowl.
Yeah,
it's insane.
He does giant spots.
A lot of money.
Oh,
insane amounts of money and it all went
away to the girl.
This tour,
it's called get that money back,
so it's called.
I wonder if he just paid off a giant
chunks.
We didn't have to pay forever.
There was a timeline on it.
Yeah,
there was a.
Yeah.
Because all this stuff was announced.
The big netflix.
I don't even want to know how much money
he paid.
I'm sure it's so much money.
It's so insane that we pretend that if
two people in a relationship,
one person makes all the money that
somehow or another there's an even deal.
So crazy.
it's so weird.
I got to piss again.
Go ahead and study.
Go piss and I'll wrap this up.
Okay.
We'll talk about your tour when you come
back.
We'll finish it up.
Are you sure?
What about the dates?
You want to give specific dates?
The tool with tommy bonds,
the no teeth,
no entry tour and uh,
all built shit aside because tommy's not
in the room right now.
There's new stuff is a little shaky.
no,
it's really funny.
He made.
I was,
he's got one bit like,
I don't want to spoiler alert it,
but he's got one bit that's like really
intricate.
And at the end of it I was like,
holy shit,
that's good.
And when you're,
when you're a funny guy like tom already
is and you're,
you know,
you're putting out stuff and then you
have to write new stuff.
THe new stuff represents the new level
of funny.
He is us the last throat clearing of
this show folks.
I promise this is a rough one,
right?
But yeah,
the fucking,
the beginning,
my throat just did not want to cooperate
and it was fine until I took one hit of
weed and then I drank some coffee and
then something about the coffee and the
weed together just produced this.
We can't do that right before we go on
stage or right before I go on the air.
Should do it like five minutes before.
And then do a lot of get that shit out
of the way.
That makes sense.
I wish there was a way to solve it,
but you can't.
You can't cough drop or anything?
No.
That would probably be better than
nothing.
But it's better now that we don't do the
butter coffee anymore.
That was fucking me up.
Too many people were complaining and
they were right.
So I took pride and try not to clear my
throat as much and I still fucked it up.
It's hard.
It's hard out there.
Tommy tommy bonds.
How wise no teeth,
no entry.
That is why not just make.
Yeah,
make fun of people.
People can buy that glass in short.
Absolutely.
They're going to come.
They're going to buy.
I'm like,
fucking crazy now.
Yeah,
just glass and bro.
Just classic.
Please tell the audience so I can have
record that you're impressed with my
water consumption.
You're the water champ.
Thank even the water champ for as long
as I've known you.
Thank you.
I mean,
I've never even seen anybody try to fuck
with you or try to take that title.
They didn't even talk about it.
You know,
like you used to be lIke people would
discuss like who was the water champ and
now let's just her,
the first time I met you,
it was in phoenix,
it was on this,
like the standup tour and you came up to
me after my set and you go,
I've never seen someone drink so much
water during such a short set.
And that was like,
wow,
it was,
I was,
I felt connected to you that you like,
that's what you saw.
And what I recognize is unusual.
It just kept drinking and no one said a
word but a,
it was almost like if you drank one more
bottled water,
someone would say something like you
were,
you're pounding the water,
but you got to the point where I don't
want to show off the water down,
but you let them know lIke you're not
fucking around.
Is this technically a water?
That's water too.
So yeah,
super,
super water champ.
This is just water with a mild amount of
flavoring in it.
But um,
so to,
to like set out to be the water champ or
is it something that just happened or
did she really have a taste?
Like a calling?
Yeah,
it's like the,
you know,
the guy set out to be the fuckIng.
I dunno the yoyo champ,
you know.
Now when you wake up in the morning,
do you get a p boners?
Are you a big boner gun?
Absolutely.
Must,
right?
Yep.
And you have to do like the straddle and
squat and you're like,
I gotta get this out of your drinking
that much water.
There's no way you're sleeping eight
hours,
right?
oh,
I wake up,
absolutely.
I have to tell myself like a child to
not to not do I do that before flight.
Sometimes you don't get 6:00
AM flight.
I'll be walking through the airport
like,
dude,
just don't fucking drink for the next
hour.
So you can sleep on the flight,
but you don't do it usually.
I can't mind my overwhelming urge to
consume more water takes.
It's a competitive thing too,
right?
It's also you're putting down numbers
and you share these online with people
and sometimes people will ask like,
how many,
you know,
like what's your record?
And I know for,
for these in a day somewhere in the
fifties and then I know that like gallon
wise it's just over three.
Yeah.
Whenever someone wants to taLk to me
about people who work out hard,
I always use the example of my friend
cameron hanes to run 205 miles and even
possibly 78 hours.
How's that savage?
He's a crazy person.
One hundred percent,
but in a good way.
Like in an overachiever.
Just a madman.
Right?
But when someone's brings up,
you know,
dude,
I know this guy drinks a lot of water.
I go,
shut the fuck up.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I said.
Shut the fuck up.
I go.
Just stop talking about your fucking
shitty friend and his shitty water
consumption.
Yeah.
You know the guy drinks?
My man,
my friend,
he dumbs like folk in 15 bottles.
Water day,
bro.
go tommy.
he make,
he might drink a thousand in a day.
[inaudible] he just get dropped off by
the pallet,
just drinks water and pays it.
Drinks water and peace at the same time.
Do I?
Sometimes he's pen while he's drinking
like You don't understand.
You're the ultimate height man.
And I feel like I should get less cold
water champions.
No,
let's go water chap.
Everybody thompson catch them on tours.
New stuff is absolutely fucking
brilliant.
You can watch two specials that are
available right now on netflix too.
Oh yeah.
He is funny,
but the new shit is even funnier.
It's well,
it's all fucking great.
Um,
tom [inaudible] dot com.com.
And go catch him out on tour.
All right,
see ya.